Der Rasenfunk-Kurzpass. Wir wollen blicken auf die europäischen Männer Top-Ligen, das heißt Serie A, La Liga und die Premier League. All das wollen wir jetzt hier besprechen in Rasenfunk-Kurzpass 267. Hallo und herzlich willkommen, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Hier ist sie wieder, die Ligatur, unser Blick auf die europäischen Top-Ligen. Und ich begrüße diesmal in einer etwas zerstücketen Sendung erst mal nur zwei Gäste bei mir. Haben wir uns auseinander gelebt? Ich weiß es nicht. Also erst mal zu meiner Linken, Christian Bernhard. Schön, dass du hier bist.
Hallihallo, schön, guten Tag.
Und dann uns zugeschaltet, Nils Kern. Hallo, Nils. Was meint ihr, sind wir jetzt wie so eine WG, die zu viel miteinander diskutiert hat und irgendwann trifft man sich nur noch irgendwie, wenn sich zwei Wege im Bad kreuzen oder beim Müll rausbringen?
Und man versucht, diese Treffen so gut es geht zu minimieren, meinst du?
Ein bisschen wirkt es so. Aber gut, immerhin, ihr beide seid noch treu geblieben. Die anderen hören wir. Wenn alles gut geht, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, es gab hier ein paar hin und her, es ging ein bisschen hin und her vor dieser Sendung. Wenn alles gut geht, dann hört ihr noch Alexis Menuge und Uli Hebel, jeweils in einzelnen Segmenten nach dem, was wir jetzt aufzeichnen. Aber ob ich euch das jetzt versprechen will, will ich, weiß ich nicht. Denn es geht natürlich die Max-Ost-Garantie, die immer bei 100 Prozent Einhaltung liegt. Deswegen gebe ich nur so eine Untervorbehalt. Schauen wir mal, was so hinhaut. Bevor wir loslegen, aber noch der Hinweis, weil wir so professionell sind, dass man uns natürlich auch finanziell unterstützen sollte. Den Rasenfunk ist ja völlig klar. Wir hatten noch nie eine Sendung, in der irgendwas technisch nicht geklappt hat. Und ganz bestimmt ist die hier auch kein Beispiel dafür. Deswegen unterstützt uns finanziell. Vielleicht können wir uns dann irgendwann ein teures Studio leisten. Wobei das wahrscheinlich heute auch nichts... Also, ihr müsstet uns so sehr unterstützen, dass wir quasi unsere Gäste per Limousine abholen könnten und dann hierher fahren können. Das wäre quasi die einzige Variante, dass es heute trotzdem geklappt hätte. Genau, rasenfunk.de slash-supporters-club. Gerne in den Verwendungszweck dann für die Limo reinschreiben. Dann weiß ich auch, dass ich das in den Limousinentopf packe, den es natürlich gibt beim Rasenfunk. Nein, ernsthaft, wir freuen uns, wenn ihr uns unterstützt. Und wir freuen uns, wenn ihr auch die anderen Formate hört. Es ist wieder wahnsinnig viel veröffentlicht worden im Rasenfunk. Zum einen ein Tribügenspräch zur Zukunft des Fußballs, eine Schlusskonferenz zum letzten Männer-Spieltag mit Fokus auf Borussia Dortmund, eine Sendung zum Frauenspieltag, der war auch sehr spektakulär. Also die beiden letzten Frauen-Bundesliga-Spieltage wirklich sehr empfehlenswert, könnt ihr nachhören. Und wenn alles gut geht, wird heute Nacht oder morgen Früh noch ein Tribügenspräch zu der ganzen DFL-Investoren-Sache erscheinen. Da sind wir nämlich auch gerade dran. Der Rasenfunk ist einfach Medienunternehmen und das läuft jetzt einfach anscheinend hier so durch 24-7. Gut, wir blicken auf die Ligen. Jetzt sind es erst mal nur zwei, die Serie A und La Liga. Nils, ich glaube, wir müssen mit dir beginnen, denn das Thema, über das wir sprechen müssen, was La Liga betrifft, hat große Wellen geschlagen und das auch zu Recht große Wellen geschlagen. Deswegen will ich es nämlich auch alles vor das Sportliche ziehen, was wir heute auch noch besprechen wollen. Es gab mal wieder einen Rassismus-Eklag gegen Vinicius Junior. Kannst du uns noch mal kurz reinholen, was ist da passiert?
Erstmal muss ich sagen, dass wir aktuell hier so dezimiert sind. Ich habe schon die Befürchtung, dass es an mir liegt, weil wenn ich im Rasenpunkt dabei bin, irgendwie bringe ich immer die negativen, nicht ganz so schönen Themen, aber auch darüber muss man natürlich reden. Denn ich war am Sonntag in Valencia im Mestalla-Stadion selbst mit dabei, als es eben mal wieder vermehrt zu rassistischen Beleidigungen Richtung Vinicius Junior gekommen ist. Schon weit auch vor Anschluss, schon bei der Busankunft gab es mehrere Mono-Mono-Rufe, sprich Affe übersetzt. Und das ist dann eben auch im Starten wiederholt. Ich meine, Valencia war im Abschiebskampf, das rechtfertigt niemals derartige Entgleisungen. Aber es ist da einfach noch mal... Wir hatten schon viele rassistische Vorfälle in La Liga, wo dann auch immer mal die Fans identifiziert wurden, dann auch vom Verein schon gesperrt wurden. Alles andere ist dann noch mal die juristische Ebene. Aber das war jetzt gefühlt dann noch mal die nächste Stufe, einfach weil sich da die Emotionen so hochgekesselt haben. Und dann stand das Spiel auch irgendwie kurz vorm Spiel ab hoch. Wenigstens wollte er aber selbst weitermachen. Ja logisch, sagt er nicht selbst, bitte aufhören hier, ich kann nicht mehr. Da hätten dann auch der Schiedsrichter dann auch den Moment verpasst, das Spiel richtig zu unterbrechen, im Sinne von in die Kabine zu gehen. So hat es auch nach dem Spiel FIFA-Präsident Gianni Infantino gesagt, von wegen so ist das Protokoll bei der FIFA. Bei La Liga hat das in dem Fall mal wieder nicht funktioniert. Und es ist einfach mal wieder nur der nächste Schritt auf diesem schlechten Weg, wo La Liga drauf ist. La Liga hat auch nach dem Spiel noch mal zusammengefasst, was sie alle schon getan haben, um Vinicius zu schützen oder zumindest, um diese Vorfälle weiterzuleiten. Da reden wir seit 2021 von zehn rassistischen Vorfällen rund um Spielen, allein acht in dieser Saison. Ob das mal nur Einzelpersonen sind, wie in Mallorca oder auch in Valladolid, wo dann eben diese Einzeltäter dann auch schnell rausgefunden werden konnten. Jetzt in Mestalla gab es auch einen Fan, auf den Vinicius klar gezeigt hat, von wegen du hast die Affengeste gemacht. Der wurde auch schnell von der Polizei rausgezogen, aber wir reden halt nicht nur von diesen zwei, drei Einzeltätern, sondern von mehreren. Und das ist da ziemlich eskaliert im Stadion. War nicht schön und hat eben so eine erneute Rassismusdebatte für einen neuen Rassismus-Eklat in Spanien gesorgt.
Kann es vielleicht sein, dass diese Debatte auch deswegen jetzt stattfindet, weil sie die ganzen letzten Male nicht so wirklich geführt wurde? Denn wenn man sich so direkt das Danach des Spiels anguckt, also zum einen Carlo Ancelotti wurde erstmal zum Sportlichen befragt, hat mehrmals nachgefragt, soll ich jetzt wirklich zum Sportlichen antworten, dass es wirklich nicht so richtig beleidigt wurde, der hat ja auch mal eine Schwalbe gemacht. Das ist ja total übel.
Jaja, oder der hat mal bei dem Torjubel auch das Wappen gezeigt. Das gibt es gar nicht. Wenigstens ist es nicht der erste Spieler, der vermeintlich provoziert, je nachdem, wie man Provokationen für sich definiert. Es rechtfertigt niemals diese Art von Beleidigung vom Fremden, von Diskriminierung. Und das ist halt eine Sache, die irgendwie in Spanien, wir sind danach auch schnell bei Pauschalisierung gewesen, sprich, dass Ancelotti gesagt hat, das ganze Mestalla hat beleidigt. Und wie Nils gesagt hat, Spanien ist ein rassistisches Land. Nein, nicht jeder Spanier auch nicht das ganze Mestalla hat. Aber es gibt schon gesellschaftliche Probleme im Land, in der Gesellschaft eben, wo dieses fremden Hass-Thema oder generell der Umgang mit anders aussehenden, anders denkenden Menschen noch nicht so weitergegangen ist, wie vielleicht bei uns in Deutschland, wo wir auch eine andere, in Anführungszeichen, cancel-Culture haben, dass dann, was sich das moren eis, oder wie auch immer, mittlerweile längst gecancelt wird, was ja völlig richtig ist, und das gibt es eben auch in Spanien und noch nicht, wo es noch viele Rumflaschen gibt, die negreta heißen, also Negerchen und so weiter, was irgendwie noch ganz normal ist. Und ja, da wird dann auch immer noch jetzt noch dieses ganze Thema unter den Teppich, nicht unter den Teppich gekehrt, weil es jetzt gerade super öffentlich ist und auch weltweit Sportler das teilen, aber wo immer noch gesagt wird, ja, aber, es gibt immer noch ein Aber dazu, und das kann es einfach nicht sein, weil wir reden nicht über normale Beleidigung, auch das sollte nicht normal sein, auch das haben Anshlotti und auch Schabi zum Thema gemacht, wie kann es sein, dass jeder hier Jürgen Ruedeputa und so weiter beleidigt wird, kann einfach nicht sein, dass es so weit geht. Und ja, auch da versuchen immer noch andere, sich rauszureden, ob das dann der FC Valencia ist, der sagt, nein, wir haben nichts getan, unsere Fangemeinde ist sauber, und die zwei, drei Einzeltäter wurden rausgezogen, aber es wird halt immer wieder weggesehen, dass es eben nicht nur diese zwei, drei Einzeltäter sind, sondern wie gesagt, in dieser Saison allein gegen wenigstens acht Vorfälle, auch bei Rüdiger gab es einen, Cádiz war es, oder in Jaki Williams, Nick Williams, Chukwese auf Mallorca, auch rassistisch beleidigt geworden. Also es ist ein großes, grundlegendes Problem, und immerhin, Vinicius und auch ein Ancelotti zeigen jetzt noch mehr auf dem Finger drauf. Vinicius ist schon im Januar in die Offensive gegangen, als er richtig auf Twitter seine Tweets verschickt hat und geschrieben hat, La Liga tut nichts dagegen, auch das verfalsche. La Liga tut ein bisschen was, offensichtlich nicht genug, und auch da versucht jetzt der Verein Riamatrida da auch lange zu eine neutrale Position gehalten, nichts groß unternommen, aber jetzt eben auch schon zwei Pressemitteilungen veröffentlicht, unter anderem auch Verbandspräsident Rubiales kritisiert, dass eben der spanische DFB, die RFE, quasi nicht die richtigen Werkzeuge an La Liga-Verband weitergegeben hat, weil La Liga hat da nicht so die Handhabe, um dann wirklich Spiel zu unterbrechen oder was weiß ich, Maßnahmen zu unternehmen. Also Ancelottis Hoffnung ist, oder Ancelotti fordert einerseits drastische Maßnahmen und hofft einfach auch, dass sich dieses System generell ändert, dass dann das Spiel abgebrochen wäre oder zumindest mal unterbrechen, in die Kabinen gehen, dann kommt es wieder raus. Wenn es dann wieder zu rassistischem Leidung kommt, dann ein Abbruch. Und da hat einfach aktuell La Liga noch keine Handhabe. Das muss sich ändern und einfach generell weiter aufmerksam aufs Thema machen, damit man irgendwo auch die Leute sich erzieht. Also es ist einfach... Allein gestern Atletico hat bei Espanyol gespielt und da gab es wieder einen Fan, der einen mit sehr ausgestreckten rechten Armen da Richtung Rodrigo de Paul beleidigt hat. Der wurde dann auch abgeführt. Also wenn es TV-Bilder gibt, die werden dann schon schnell identifiziert. Aber wir reden auch in Valencia von so vielen privaten Handyaufnahmen, wo du irgendwie 200 Leute vor dir siehst und einer macht gerade ne Gnodemierde. Und da ist es dann schwer, die Leute zu identifizieren. Aber es zeigt einfach, wie groß das Problem ist, dass einfach in diesem möglichen, nicht rechtsfreien Raum Fußball, wo irgendwie eine vermeintliche Anonymität herrscht, dass dort manche sich auslassen, als wäre es im privaten Raum, was man im privaten Raum auch nicht tun sollte. Aber es kann nicht sein, dass da, La Liga gibt einfach ein sehr, sehr, sehr schlechtes Bild aktuell im Weltfußball ab.
Gut, du siehst eben im Fußball, wie Gesellschaften ticken. Und ich meine, dass wir da auch in Deutschland noch nicht weit sind, hat Boris Palmer jüngst bewiesen durch die Verwendung des N-Words. Jetzt haben wir es hier leider auch einmal verwendet. Entschuldigung dafür, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Christian, ich bin so ein bisschen ratlos, weil natürlich der Fußball kann diese Probleme nicht lösen, aber wir sehen sie im Fußball. Und jetzt haben wir hier in dem Bereich jetzt auch einen Verband, der zumindest wenig tut und nicht nur in der Außendarstellung eine Untätigkeit symbolisiert. Jetzt haben wir solche Themen auch in Deutschland, auch in der Serie A. Wir haben sie in allen Ligen. Wie blickst du denn auf so was, was da passiert ist?
Ich muss sagen, vieles, was Nils jetzt erzählt hat, das gibt es so in Abstufungen auch in Italien. Wer sich vielleicht dran erinnert, vor kurzem war Romelu Lukaku beim Coppa Italia Halbfinalspiel in Turin, wo es solche Szenen gab, wo danach dann auch, ich glaube auch eine parallele Nils, oder? Da hat dann der Verband die Sperre für Lukaku zurückgenommen, um einfach ein Signal zu setzen. Also Lukaku hat damals gelb-rot gesehen, weil sein Jubel als provokativ ausgelegt worden ist vom Schiri. Und danach hat der Verbandspräsident das zurückgenommen, einfach als ein Symbol zu setzen. Wenn ich richtig informiert bin, Nils, korrigiere mich gerne, hat das der Verband in Spanien jetzt ja auch gemacht, die Sperre für Vinicius. Was mich da überrascht hat, ist, dass Xavi dann auf einer Pressekonferenz meinte, also der Barca-Trainer, er versteht jetzt nicht, warum diese Sperre nicht sozusagen bestehen bleibt, weil es ja für Aktionen auf dem Feld sozusagen verhängt worden ist. Jetzt kann man rein regelmäßig das definitiv so sehen, keine Frage. Ich frage mich nur, ob sich da nicht alle Beteiligten nicht wirklich in Gefallen tun, wenn man nicht wirklich... Also ich bin weit davon entfernt zu sagen, ja, der Verband nimmt jetzt eine Strafe zurück, wunderbar, das löst das Problem. Nein, das löst das Problem logischerweise nicht. Aber ich finde, es ist zumindest mal ein erstes Symbol, eine erste Geste. Und wenn das dann auch wieder von Konkurrenten sozusagen in Frage gestellt wird, dann weiß ich nicht, ob wir da wirklich auf dem richtigen Weg sind. Ein Beispiel noch dazu, Gasparini, vor kurzem in Italien gab es wieder einen ähnlichen Fall, da ist Flauowitsch von Juve bei Atalanta aufgrund seiner slawischen Herkunft diffamiert worden und da hat sich Gasparini danach hingestellt und gemeint, ja, aber das ist für ihn nicht Rassismus, sondern das ist für ihn Beleidigung quasi. Und damit will ich nur sagen, anscheinend sind viele im System noch, haben noch nicht diese Denke, dass eben diese Spieler sozusagen da in was reingeraten, was für sie wirklich sehr, sehr übel ist und dementsprechend, ich bin wirklich froh, muss ich sagen, dass Vinicius und Ancelotti das so klar jetzt darauf hingewiesen haben, weil es eben nicht nur um den Fußball geht, sondern ja ganz die ganze gesellschaftliche Dynamik betrifft.
Zumindest jetzt bei der roten Karte in Valencia war dann nochmal eine andere Szene, da ging es im Endeffekt war eine Rudelbildung, Vinicius war irgendwo im Schwitzkasten, 10 Sekunden, hat sich dann so ein bisschen befreit und dann gab es die Hand ins Gesicht, also ein Wischer. Dafür kann man rot geben, keiner hat gefordert, dass die rote Karte aufgehoben wurde, also war das Ancelotti hat auch gestern auf der Pressekonferenz in Bernabéu, da war ich dabei gesagt, der wurde da von auch überrascht, dass das aufgehoben wurde, hat keiner gefordert zumal Vinicius eh aktuell angeschlagen, leicht verletzt ist. Das hat schon sehr geschmeckt nach, guck mal, wir machen das für euch, sind wir jetzt wieder Freunde. Also das kann es, das reicht natürlich lange nicht und das Mestalla wird jetzt auch in fünf Heimspielen die Südkurve gesperrt, 45.000 Euro Strafe, das wird auch nicht reichen, also es geht einfach um was Grundlegendes, auch um das System, wenn es zu rassistischem Leidigen kommt, dass dann ein Spiel unterbrochen wird, dass man so dann diese Maßnahmen antritt, dass man vielleicht auch dann die Täter irgendwie kennzeichnet, zumindest die spanische Polizei hat dann auch Videos geteilt, wie dann die Täter in Handschellen genommen wurden, abgeführt wurden, natürlich ohne jetzt das Gesicht zu zeigen, also um da auch ein bisschen Transparenz zu schaffen, dass nicht nur die Opfer im Fokus sind, sondern man dann auch zeigt dann die Täter ein bisschen, ohne dass es jetzt die Megalinch-Justiz wird, aber es muss sich viel ändern und die große Karte war dann einfach dubios, weil wie gesagt hat keiner gefordert, dass es aufgehoben wird, dann hätte es eher noch für Hugo Dudo, der ihn im. Jetzt gab es die Strafen eben für den FC Valencia und auch vier Monate später für eine, ihr erinnert euch vielleicht an die Vinicius-Puppe, die im Januar an der Brücke gebaumelt hat von den Atletico-Fans. Da jetzt auf einmal wurden auch hier noch drei, vier Leute festgenommen von der spanischen Polizei, hat sie auch geteilt. Also auch das jetzt auf einmal geht's, obwohl klar war, welcher Fanclub das war von Atletico. Alles sehr, sehr dubios und viel Hoffnung, dass sich das grundlegend ändert, habe ich nicht. Aber so viel Druck und Öffentlichkeit und Bereichweite, wie aktuell da ist, geht auch nicht.
Ich glaube, ein Satz vielleicht noch aus italienischer Perspektive, ich weiß nicht, wie das in Spanien gelebt wird. Ich glaube, da ist nicht nur der Verband gefordert, sondern sehr auch die Vereine. Und in Italien merkt man jetzt zumindest ein kleines Anfangen. Juve zum Beispiel, da wurden wirklich, ich glaube, das waren sogar Andi Hundert, die wurden identifiziert damals in diesem Blog, die angeblich diese rassistischen Beleidigungen geäußert haben. Und die bekamen von Juve ein Stadionverbot. Ähnliches sogar bei Lazio. Wir wissen alle, bei Lazio ein Riesenproblem, aber Lazio hat auch zuletzt Einzelne, die identifiziert werden konnten, sozusagen mit ihrem eigenen Regelkatalog bestraft. Und die kommen jetzt nicht mehr ins Stadion. Ist vielleicht ein Anfang, dass die Sache eben nicht nur beim Verband oder bei der Liga liegt, sondern dass das muss ein Miteinander sein zwischen Liga, Vereine, dass da wirklich hart durchgegriffen wird und dass dadurch vielleicht eine Besserung auch mittelfristig auf den Weg kommt?
Ja, gab es und gibt es auch schon, wenn es eben zu diesen Einzeltätern wie in Valladolid auf Mallorca kam, die haben dann auch, da haben dann die Vereine, ich glaube, jeweils eine zweijährige Stadionssperre im eigenen Stadion verkündet, aber ohne, dass es mir jetzt bekannt ist, dass das irgendwie national oder ligaweit gilt und auch jetzt ist da ja die drei, vier, die festgenommen wurden. Da war dann auch der FC Valencia in seiner Mitteilung ganz klar von wegen lebenslanges. Miss-Taja-Verbot ist auch schon mal 2019 nach einem Vorfall in Europa League so passiert, aber wie gesagt, wir reden nicht nur über die zwei, drei, vier, sondern über die 100, die vorm Spiel schwer nachzuvollziehen, weil vielleicht hatten nicht jeder eine Eintrittskarte und auch die anderen 100, die im Stadion das machen und die dann zu identifizieren, ist schwierig, aber ja, es ist auf jeden Fall, der Verband muss aktiv werden, aber es müssen auch die Vereine, was wiedergeben an ihre Fans, damit die Fans merken, so geht es einfach nicht weiter. Also da muss es klare, viele Strafen geben, drastische Maßnahmen, wie Ancelotti es fordert.
Ja, und eben langfristige, positiv gestrickte Dinge, also durch Sanktionen verschiebst du das Problem immer nur. Also was bringt es uns, wenn Rassisten Stadionverbot haben? Sie sind außerhalb der Stadion noch weiter ihre Rassisten. Also und das ist halt das viel schwerer zu erreichende. Gleichzeitig sehen wir meinem Eindruck nach, dadurch, dass es in so vielen Ländern grassiert, glaube ich, dass ich an so Dingen wie Rassismus auch mit ablesen lässt, welche Stimmungslage in Gesellschaften herrscht. Wenn Angst herrscht, wenn Ungleichheit herrscht, wenn Angst vor Armut usw. herrscht, dann war es in der Geschichte schon sehr häufig so, dass dafür eben dann Minderheiten systematisch dafür diskriminiert wurden. Also wer sich mit der Entstehungsgeschichte von Rassismus beschäftigt, der ja letztlich aus der Kolonialzeit kommt, so eine Verquickung aus Industrialisierung, Kapitalismus und Kolonialzeit und man sich letztlich quasi nur rechtfertigen musste, warum man andere Länder komplett ausbeuten kann und bis hin zu Menschenleben, die man nicht als menschenlebenswert erachtet. Wenn man sich damit beschäftigt, wenn man sich damit beschäftigt, warum Antisemitismus schon so so viele, hunderte, fast schon tausende Jahre in Gesellschaften hängen, dann hängt es eben ganz oft damit zusammen, dass man einen Grund gebraucht hat, um Dinge zu rechtfertigen. Und vielleicht sehen wir an solchen Entwicklungen, die es überall gibt, auch in Deutschland, dass sich die Stimmungslage verschärft, aus welchen Gründen auch immer. Vielleicht nehmen wir es auch nur mehr wahr. Das ist jetzt eine Interpretationsfrage. Aber das sollte dann auch ein Hinweis darauf sein. So wichtig es ist, dass die Fußballvereine und dass die Fußballverbände sich völlig klar positionieren, weil sie eben auch eine hohe Symbolkraft haben, muss es halt begleitende Maßgaben geben. Im Fußball und dann aber auch in den Gesellschaften. Der Fußball kann es nicht alleine lösen. Aber das ist der eine Aspekt, den ich zumindest noch kurz gemacht haben wollte. Sanktionen sind wichtig und richtig, aber sie werden das Problem leider überhaupt nicht lösen. Gerade in Deutschland kannst du das perfekt ablösen. Deutschland tut ja immer so, als hätte es durch den Zweiten Weltkrieg alles gelernt. Antisemitismus. In München war im letzten Jahr an jedem Tag drei antisemitische Straftaten nach den jüngsten Zahlen, die da gegeben wurden. Also quasi statistisch gesehen. An jedem Tag. Also da möchte ich mal darüber diskutieren, wie gut Deutschland wirklich seine Lektion gelernt hat, wenn man das überhaupt so sagen kann. Also es ist ein großes Problem, aber deswegen wollte ich dem hier auch so einen Raum einräumen. Und ich habe aber auch das Gefühl, wir werden noch häufiger über solche Dinge sprechen, egal in welcher Liga. Und dann ist es ja aber auch wichtig, das zu thematisieren. Dann versuchen wir mal, zum Sportlichen zu kommen. Wir probieren es mal, wo wir wissen, dass es eigentlich viel, viel weniger wichtig ist. Es läuft gut in Pokalwettbewerben für italienische Teams, in europäischen Pokalwettbewerben und jetzt gibt es aber auch einen nationalen, auf den man sich freuen kann. Warum denn?
Genau, ja ganz frisch. Gestern Abend, also Mittwochabend, hat das Coppa Italia-Finale stattgefunden. Das ist vielleicht, damit schafft man vielleicht eine kleine Überleitung. Es war wirklich ein schönes Fußballfest im Stadio Olimpico in Rom. Wirklich immer ein ganz besonderes Ambiente beim Finale, jeweils 25.000, also beide Vereine haben 25.000 Anhänger in ihren Kurven. Gestern großartige Choreos, sowohl von der Fiorentina als auch von Inter. Also wirklich ein Fußballfest und das Spiel hat auch sehr viel hergegeben. Also Inter hat das Finale 2-1 gewonnen, nach frühem Rückstand. Nico González, ehemalige Stuttgarter, argentinischer Nationalspieler, hat die Fiorentina frühen Führung gebracht und Lautaro Martinez, sein argentinischer Gegenpart, hat noch mit einem Doppelpack vor der Pause sozusagen Inter in Führung gebracht. Diese Führung hat dann gereicht. Man muss sagen, Inter hat sehr viel leiden müssen in der zweiten Hälfte. Die Fiorentina hat das großartig gemacht, hat sich Riesenschanzen rausgespielt. Allein Lukajovic ist eingewechselt worden, hatte zwei Riesendinger. Also es hat wenig gefehlt und das Spiel hätte eigentlich in die Verlängerung gehen können, sollten. Aber Inter hat es irgendwie geschafft und hat jetzt unter Insagi ein zweites Jahr unter Insagi. Der vierte Titel ist schonmal eingefahren. Letztes Jahr Coppa Italia, Supercoppa. Dieses Jahr Supercoppa gegen Milan, der Derby souverän gewonnen. Jetzt der nächste Titel und es steht ja noch ein Finale an für Inter in ein paar Wochen. Also Insagi hat sich wieder mal als absoluter Pokal- und K.O.-Spiele-Spezialist bewiesen.
Und kann man sagen, woran das liegt? Dass es in den Pokal-Wettbewerben so, also es ist ja in der Liga nicht schlecht, aber es ist besser noch in den Pokal-Wettbewerben.
Deutlich besser. Ja, Insagi ist logisch oft danach gefragt worden. Ich habe gesagt, es gibt kein wirkliches Geheimnis. Aber es scheint schon ein Gespür dafür zu haben, eben die Spieler, die Mannschaft eben in solchen 90 Minuten oder oft 180 Minuten, wenn es hin und rückspielt geht, so einzustellen, dass sie wissen, was Sache ist. Das hat ja eine Vorgeschichte bei Inter. Alle reden jetzt über das Champions-League- Finale und sagen vielleicht ein paar, die hatten jetzt Milan, davor hatten sie Benfica und Porto in den K.o.-Spielen. Sind die nicht die größten Namen? Es mag vielleicht sein, aber ich erinnere daran, dass Inter in einer Vorrundengruppe mit Barca und Bayern war. Und da ging ja für Inter auch schon dieser K.o.-Modus los. Und gerade in den zwei Spielen gegen Barca hat Inter das geschafft, warum sie weitergekommen sind. Sie haben das Hinspiel im San Siro 1-0 gewonnen und haben im Rückspiel wirklich diesem Sturm von Barca standgehalten, haben dann am Ende dieses spektakuläre 3-3, hatten am Ende ja auch diese riesen Konterschanzen, weil Barca gewinnen musste. Aber das zeigt eben schon für mich, in K.o.-Spielen war Inter schon die ganze Saison über da. Und wenn wir einen kleinen Bogen sogar noch zur Vorsaison nehmen, da ist Inter zum ersten Mal seit vielen Jahren aus der Champions-League- Gruppenphase raus und hatte dann Liverpool im Achtelfinale. Vielleicht erinnert sich noch der eine oder andere. Und es war Liverpool damals noch in seiner Prime. Liverpool dann ja auch im Finale und da hat Liverpool das Hinspiel in San Siro 2-0 gewonnen mit zwei späten Toren. Leistungsmäßig war da Inter eindeutig näher dran und das Rückspiel hat Inter in der Einfeld-Tour sogar 1-0 gewonnen. Das hat dann zwar nicht gereicht, aber ich finde, da hat man schon erkannt, dass in Sargi eben dieser Mannschaft in solchen K.o.-Spielen es mit auf den Weg gibt, Fokus, was sie zu tun haben, die richtige Schärfe und dementsprechend ist das jetzt ein roter Faden, also ein positiver roter Faden, der sich durchzieht. Und ich finde, man muss jetzt über In Sargi sprechen, denn vielleicht erinnert euch auch noch, ich glaube auch hier in der Sendung vor ein paar Wochen, da war In Sargi mehr oder weniger fast zum Abschluss freigegeben. Auch in Italien wahnsinnig viel Druck und jetzt steht er da als Trainer, der eben wie gesagt in seiner zweiten Saison den vierten Titel inne hat, der die Mannschaft ins Champions League-Final geführt hat, das seit 13 Jahren nicht mehr der Fall war und der jetzt auch in der Liga durch so einen Zwischensport eigentlich mehr oder weniger die Champions League-Quali wieder eingetütet hat. Also ich finde es beeindruckend, wie ihn sage ich, da die Ruhe bewahrt hat, das Ganze weg moderiert hat und das eine ist das Kommunikative, das Moderative, aber hat in dieser Zeit ja auch die Mannschaft dahin gebracht, dass die jetzt in dieser entscheidenden Phase so on point da ist. Ich würde sagen, ihm ist das gelungen, was jeder Trainer sich wünscht vor der Saison, dass du in der entscheidenden Saisonphase sowohl physisch als auch mental sozusagen auf deinem Höhepunkt bist. Also ich muss sagen, ich glaube, es gibt viele auch Beobachter, die vorhin sage jetzt, die sich nach der Saison da vielleicht auch noch überlegen müssen, wie sie mit ihm umgegangen sind. Ganz interessant, ihn sage ich jetzt auch vor kurzem mal gesagt, er hat sich wirklich immer total zurückgehalten, aber er hat nur einmal jetzt den Satz fallen lassen, ich weiß ganz genau, während welcher Phase sozusagen von wem ich Unterstützung bekommen habe und von wem nicht. Das ist vielleicht auch ein bisschen...
Kalt kälter hier geworden als du es zitiert hast.
Ja, das eine ist, viel interpretieren das so Richtung als Medialer sozusagen, aber ich glaube, da geht es schon auch intern rein, denn bei Marotta, dem Sportdirektor, also das Verhältnis zwischen Marotta und Insagi war nicht immer das leichteste und da gab es auch intern großen Druck, aber Insagi hat das wie gesagt eben souverän weg moderiert und jetzt stell mal vor, am 10. Juni würde das passieren, was mit wem vielleicht im Moment, mit dem wenige rechnen, aber ja, dann würde er wahrscheinlich als der König der Welt dastehen. Also ich muss echt sagen, Respekt wie gesagt, wie er das gemacht hat und auch noch mal nur ganz kurz zur Einordnung, wo Inter herkam. Also Inter, als er es übernommen hat, da ist Antonio Conte, ja, ein bisschen durch die Hintertür wieder mal weg, Lukaku wurde in dem Sommer verkauft, Hakimi wurde in dem Sommer verkauft und Christian Eriksen aus anderen Gründen, aus gesundheitlichen Gründen hat dann nicht mehr für Inter spielen können. Also diese Mannschaft hat ihn sage übernommen und jetzt hat er sie innerhalb von zwei Jahren ins Champions League Finale geführt, hat nebenbei noch vier Titel eingesammelt. Also ich frage mich, was ein Trainer mehr tun muss oder soll, als ein gutes Standing zu bekommen.
Vor allem hat er ja jetzt auch Lukaku wieder hinbekommen, dass Lukaku auch wieder voll integriert ist und Motivation zeigt.
Ja, es gibt viele Beispiele, du sagst es, Lukaku ist eins, auch Cialanullo zum Beispiel. Cialanullo war, glaube ich, bis vor dieser Saison hat jeder als den technischen, den Zehner, den Achter, der nach vorne logisch immer für Momente gut ist, aber der jetzt vielleicht nicht der überragende Spieler gegen den Ball ist. Wenn du anschaust, der hat in dieser Saison im wahnsinnig lang auf der Sechs gespielt, weil Brozovic sozusagen verletzt war. Auch gestern gab es ein paar Momente, wo er gegen den Ball in der Rückwärtsbewegung extrem wichtige Zweikämpfe geführt hat und auch da, das hat Cialanullo auch vor ein paar Wochen im Interview gesagt, das war wahnsinnig gute Arbeit von Insagi mit mir. Klar war das auch eine große Leistung des Spielers, aber erkannt hat das erstmal Insagi, ihn auch auf dieser Position gewinnbringend einbringen zu können sozusagen. Und also dieses Miteinander funktioniert. Dumfries ist auch ein gutes Beispiel. Der war immer wieder offensiv für alles mögliche gut, aber nach hinten, puh, immer wieder mal Probleme. Dumfries ist im Moment auch total scharf gegen den Ball. Vielleicht erinnern sich noch ein paar Champions League-Halbfinale-Rückspiele gegen Milan, da hat es Dumfries mit Theo Hernandez und Leao zu tun bekommen. Die hat das sehr gut im Griff gehabt. Klar, nicht alleine, das war auch wieder das Kollektiv. Da hilft Barella mit, da hilft Bastoni mit, aber wie Nils sagt, du kannst jetzt auch an vielen Einzelspielern ablesen, dass in Sarge da wirklich mit seinem Trainerteam einfach sehr, sehr gute Arbeit geleistet hat oder leistet immer noch.
Ja und dann Spieler, die einfach vielleicht so den umgedrehten WM-Effekt hatten, den man hier in der Bundesliga beim FC Bayern sehen kann, die halt einfach, also laut Harumati-Rinnen ist, das ist ja der Wahnsinn.
Also gestern auch, der steht jetzt bei 26 Saison-Toren, hat seinen Rekord aus der vergangenen Saison jetzt übertroffen, hat er 25 mal für Inter wettbewerbsübergreifend getroffen. Gestern eines davon war sein 100. Tor für Liga. Also der junge Mann, ich würde sagen, ist immer noch eher ein junger Mann. Also schaut euch an, das zweite Tor, wie er das auch macht. Also das wirklich, da siehst du halt was Selbstvertrauen auch mit dem Spieler und mit der Mannschaft machen kann. Es war gestern auch ein gutes Beispiel dafür, die Fiorentiner, frühe Führung, hat wirklich Inter Probleme bereitet, aber Inter ist total ruhig geblieben. Die haben sich die Fiorentiner ein bisschen zurecht gelegt, haben sie gelesen, hatten dann eben diese Chancen, haben sie genutzt, hatten hinten raus auch ein bisschen Glück, bleibe ich dabei. Aber du siehst eben, wenn eine Mannschaft, wenn ein Spieler Selbstvertrauen hat und ich finde Lautaro ist da immer ein wunderbares Beispiel. Es gibt ein Lautaro mit Selbstvertrauen und einen ohne. Und jetzt siehst du, der weiß, was er tut, der braucht nicht viel, der arbeitet auch für die Mannschaft. Passt wunderbar in dieses Bild mit rein.
Ja, verrückt. Inter, wie sich das gedreht hat. Das ist irre. Das ist ungefähr so, als wäre Nagelsmann geblieben und hätte jetzt auf einmal zwei Titel geholt. Dann hätten wir uns alle bei ihm entscheiden müssen. Ja, wir nicht.
Also wie gesagt, noch als letzter Satz, wenn ich sage, er hat noch nicht dieses internationale Standing. Das ist klar, er hat vielleicht auch noch nicht den Namen. Aber wie gesagt, jetzt über mehrere Jahre, ich frage mich und ich habe mich das auch schon vor ein paar Wochen gefragt, als die Kritik so groß war. Ich dachte mir, ja gut, jetzt warten wir halt erstmal ab und jetzt kommt es ja so, wie es eben wieder positive Fallheit einfach ist. Er kommt über Liga wieder in die Champions League und er steht jetzt im Champions League- Finale und wie gesagt, für Inter 13 Jahre haben sie auf diesen Moment gewartet. Also es ist jetzt nicht die Selbstverständlichkeit, es ist nicht das Inter, das alle drei Jahre hat. Und dann frage ich mich schon, ja, welche Erwartungen hast du denn noch an den Trainer? Letzter Satz noch, Inter hat allein in dieser Saison durch den Champions League-Run mindestens um die 100 Millionen Euro eingenommen. Also auch das zeigt, dass dieser Weg ja auch für den Verein ein wichtiger Weg ist, weil ja, wir wissen alle, sind jetzt nicht alle gerade auf Rosen gebetet wirtschaftlich und wenn du dann durch so einen Weg dann auch noch so ein massives Plus dir erwirtschaftest, dann glaube ich, kann der Präsident mehr als zufrieden sein mit dem, was sein Trainer da so macht.
Das klingt so und dann sind wir mal gespannt, wie der Sportdirektor in Zukunft zufrieden sein wird. Eigentlich war der Nagelsmann-Vergleich gar nicht so schlecht, denn wenn Nagelsmann gesagt hätte, ich weiß schon genau wer, dann hätten wir auch alle gesagt, na hat er jetzt gerade die Bild-Zeitung gemeint oder was? Naja, das ist ein anderes Thema. Vielleicht denke ich zu sehr gedanklich in der Bundesliga immer fest. Dann wollen wir noch über etwas völlig überraschendes reden, Nils, mit dem niemand rechnen konnte. Der FC Sevilla steht im Finale der Europa League. Wann gab es denn das zuletzt?
Das gab es zuletzt 2020 und war damals schon ihr sechstes Finale. Auch das hatten sie gewonnen. Also die Roma muss aufpassen, jetzt ist das Finale. Das sind innerhalb von 17 Jahren. Das ist unfassbar. Es gibt ja beim FC Sevilla diesen Slogan, der heißt Nadje laciere come uno sottros. Keiner will es so sehr wie wir. Und das haben sie gegen United gezeigt, gegen Juve gezeigt und der steht für mehr.
Weil die haben in ihrem Slogan drinstehen, dass sie es mehr wollen.
Nein, nicht im Feinslogan, aber es ist so ihr Spruch, den sie da öfter mal raushauen, den dann die Presse überall hat, den Spieler sagen und den es dann was sich auf Grafiken gibt. Also das ist...
Da kenne ich ja mehrere deutsche TV-Experten, die endlich erregt sind wie ich. Das ist ja ein Traum. Wir wollen es mehr.
Ja, die Mentalität ist da sehr hoch beim FC Sevilla.
Aber hoffentlich spielen sie nicht auf Zeit. Das darf man nicht gegen deutsche Teams. Das ist kein Fußball. Möchte ich nichts sehen.
Ja gut, das hat jetzt zumindest Akunja, die das Finale gekostet, weil er hatte dann die Gelb-Rote-Durchzeitspiel eben gesehen. Bisschen übertrieben vielleicht. Aber gut, nein, der FC Sevilla spielt eine sehr kuriose Achterbahn-Saison. Also es war am 14. Januar, da war man noch vorletzter in der Tabelle in der Liga. Sampaoli war dann noch im Amt, bis März auch. Es lief eigentlich okay, aber die Mannschaft hatte einfach so viele Disziplin-Probleme, war einfach übermotiviert, so viele Karten gesammelt, auch immer noch irgendwie zweitmeistend in der Liga. Und dann Ende März ist dann José Luis Medellí-Bar gekommen, so ein sehr erfahrener alter baskischer Trainer, der einfach die Mannschaft sehr stabilisiert hat, die Ordnung zurückgebracht hat, das ist alles ein bisschen immer noch motiviert, aber mit ein bisschen mehr Coolheit mittlerweile. Und ja, der hat jetzt von seinen allerersten vier Europa-League-Spielen United Juventus 2 gewonnen, zwar unentschieden, also keins verloren und ist damit so ins Finale eingezogen. Auch in der Liga natürlich ging es nach oben. Platz 9. Da hat man noch kleine Chancen auf die Conference League, auf den 7. Platz in La Liga. Also da läuft es mehr oder weniger spektakulär, weil auch die Winter-Transfers mehr und mehr funktionieren. Ja, die hatten Sampaoli auch, aber da hat man vielleicht auch ihre Zeit gebraucht. So ein Loic Bardet aus Frankreich, Willkommen, Pappé Gouet und auch Rückkehrer Ocampos und Brian Hill, die einfach sehr viel tun beim FC Sevilla, spielen das Vertrauen und bekommen haben. Und da einfach die Abwehrprobleme von der Vorsaison als ja wichtige Spiele wie auch in Koundé gegangen verkauft wurden, die das da einfach aufgehoben wurden. Also ja, sehr überraschend. Der FC Sevilla steht im Europa League Finale.
Ja, aber das ist ja gut, dass du noch mal diesen weiteren Bogen spannst, dass man eben auch in der Liga mit rangekommen ist und du hast jetzt von der Conference League gesprochen, aber man könnte ja durch einen Sieg im Europa League Finale, wenn ich jetzt nicht komplett falsch informiert bin, sogar in die Champions League kommen. Das wäre ja jetzt auch nicht so schlecht.
Allein deshalb, genau, Nils, weil du es sagst, allein deshalb das Finale noch doppelt brisant, weil für die Roma ist dieser Weg ja auch dieses Tor da. Die Roma wird es über die Liga wahrscheinlich auch nicht mehr schaffen. Deswegen allein, dass beide Mannschaften sozusagen jetzt auch noch die Aussicht haben auf die Champions League. Aber eins hat es auch von mir, also ich finde es wirklich beeindruckend Sevilla. Also das ist echt, ich habe das Juve-Rückspiel auch gesehen, auch das Juve-Hinspiel. Jetzt ist klar, Juve ist im Moment nicht die große europäische Mannschaft, aber Juve findet dann halt auch in so einem K.o.-Spiel irgendwie, macht es dir unangenehm, bleibt im Spiel, aber trotzdem, also was da in der Verlängerung auch im Stadion los war, also das ist echt beeindruckend. Dann auch La Mela, auch einer von diesen Ewigen, der irgendwie gefühlt ja schon weiß Gott, wie lange dabei ist, da macht der das entscheidende Tor. Du sagst es ja, ich finde, das muss man schon hoch genug einschätzen, die nehmen einfach United in der Runde davor raus durch einen 3-0 im Rückspiel. Also United, da reden wir jetzt von einer der Top-Mannschaften der Premier League. Und da sagst du ja wie einfach, nö, danke, Europa League, nicht mit uns.
Das ist unser Wettbewerb, die wollen es mir.
Also ich finde, das ist schon sehr beeindruckend, was die da auch über so eine lange Zeitspanne halt einfach zeigen. Wirklich beeindruckend, ja.
Absolut, man kriegt da auch, also ich kriege jetzt schon wieder Gänsehaut, wenn ich da nur allein an das United-Rückspiel denke, wie auch das Sanchez-Piz 1 sich da präsentiert. Allen weiß jetzt gegenüber, im Rückspiel waren alle in rot. Die leben das einfach komplett und wollen es und sind einfach bei 100 Prozent da und die Mannschaft überträgt das auf den Platz. Und ja, das sind alles diese Schlossgänse, mehr Wille und Motivation, aber da ist wirklich Sevilla eine ganz besondere Mannschaft, wenn die Europa-Likümmer läuft. Ich meine, letztes Jahr haben sie es ja auch so ein bisschen. Champions League-Gruppenphase, okay, Platz drei, die hatten das Finale zu Hause irgendwie im Visier, hat dann nicht geklappt, West Ham sind rausgeflogen letztes Jahr, aber auch dieses Jahr so ein bisschen die Einnahmen aus der Champions League-Gruppenphase mitgenommen, so wie in Platz drei und jetzt marschieren sie wieder durch. Das ist ja, eigentlich ist es genial, weil du weißt, du hast immer die Chancen, die in dem anderen Turnier dann noch und kannst dich da dann noch für die Champions League qualifizieren. Also komplett verrückt, aber auch nicht verdient, weil einfach United da komplett überfordert war. Juve im Rückspiel hatte sehr gefährliche Momente, auf jeden Fall vor allem im ersten Durchgang, aber auch da einfach irgendwie cool geblieben, ruhig geblieben und am Ende dann eben doch noch mit Lamela per Kopf dabei gewesen. Also stark war ja auch noch eine Auffalljagd. Juve hat ja noch geführt im Rückspiel. Also sensationell, was die da immer wieder abreißen. Und so ging es einfach jetzt die letzten Wochen ganz gut bergauf. Jetzt hat man mal gegen Elche den Tabellenletzten schon abgestiegen, nur 1-1 gespielt, aber es ist halt der Fokus schon auf was ganz anderes. Das macht mir als Matridist auch Hoffnung. Samstag fahre ich auch in Real Madrid in Sevilla, da hoffe ich dann, dass sie da ein bisschen schon viel geschont wird, rotiert wird und woanders gedanklich schon sind.
Ich würde gerade sagen, wir können ein bisschen gespannt sein auf die Aufstehung von Sevilla am Wochenende und von der Roma. Da werden wir schon viel rauslesen, worauf der Fokus liegt quasi.
Ai, ai, ai. Und noch der kurze Hinweis, wie bezarr das gewesen sein muss für Filip Kostić, der fast auf den Tag genau, glaube ich, ein Jahr nachdem er in Sevilla die Europa League gewonnen hat, dann beim Stand von 1 zu 1 erst eingewechselt wird und dann in der Verlängerung rausgeht. Wenn wir jetzt kurz bei der Juve hier auch noch sind, haben wir vorher nicht abgesprochen, aber können wir auch noch ganz kurz drüber sprechen über die neueste Entscheidung, die es da gab?
Ja, müssen wir auch. Klar, ja. Also, es wurde jetzt noch mal ein Urteil gefällt. Es sind minus 10 Punkte geworden, Juve, dadurch jetzt schon mal weit aus den Champions.
Also es waren erst minus 15, dann null, und jetzt sind es wieder minus 10.
Ja, wobei diese null, also die wurden erst mal einfach zurückgenommen und jetzt sozusagen ist es jetzt bei minus 10 gelandet. War wirklich ein extrem kurioser Tag. Juve hat an dem Tag am Abend auch noch Ligaspiel in Empoli gehabt, und das Urteil kam eine Viertelstunde vor Spielbeginn. Und dann ist Juve in Empoli mit 1 zu 4 untergegangen. Wo Allegri, ich finde, das kann man ihm auch zugute halten, gemeint hat, ja, pfuh, das ist den Spielern dann halt schwer zu vermitteln, wenn zehn Minuten vor dem Spiel, die dann plötzlich, wenn du ihnen klarmachen musst, übrigens, wir in der Tabelle sind jetzt dann halt auch, was sind sie jetzt, auf sieben quasi. Also es soll keine Ausrede sein, aber es zeigt schon die ganze Saison für Juve, man muss ja auch sagen für die Mitkonkurrenten, also das war jetzt schon extrem unglücklich, diese ganze Nummer, denn eigentlich über mehrere Monate war die Tabelle, ja, kannst du sagen...
So immer unter Vorbehalt.
Genau, Mourinho hat sich ja auch logischerweise hat sich das nicht nehmen, der hatte schon ein paar mal gesagt, oh, die Meisterschaft ist sozusagen Falsato, also...
Deswegen sind die alle in den europäischen Pokalwettbewerb so weit gekommen.
Genau, weil sich alle auf den europäischen Wettbewerb konzentriert haben. Nee, also das muss man schon wirklich sagen, ich glaube, das ist jetzt eine Geschichte auch für die italienische Sportgerichtsbarkeit, die das auch schon erkannt hat, dass sie gesagt, wir müssen da andere Wege finden. Also ich finde, ich meine, man hat nicht alle Jahre einen Fall, dass ein Top-Verein in Europa irgendwie aufgrund staatsanwaltschaftlicher Ermittlungen sozusagen in Fokus gerät und du dann auch als Sportgerichtsbarkeit logisch gefordert ist. Also ich würde mal sagen, da gibt es jetzt nicht einen Katalog, wo einfach drin steht, so handelt man das. Aber klar ist so, wie es jetzt in Italien gehandelt wurde, das ist für alle Beteiligten nicht gut. Und dementsprechend ist es jetzt für Juve, was dieser Montag des Schreckchens sozusagen erst die Minus 10, dann 1.4. in Empoli. Und du merkst halt einfach, und das kann ich auch nachvollziehen, wie willst du einen, die Maria, sozusagen motivieren in so einer Situation und sagen, hey Junge, noch mal alles raushauen, der schaut dich wahrscheinlich an und sagt, ja wie, die haben uns jetzt gerade, einmal waren es Minus 15, jetzt sind es Minus 10, jetzt sind wir 7. Die wollen uns eh nicht in Europa haben, so ungefähr. Also das ist schon keine einfache Aufgabe, finde ich. Und dementsprechend ist es gut, wenn das Thema jetzt durch ist. Es ist noch nicht komplett durch, es gibt ja auch noch andere Ermittlungen, da kommt womöglich noch was und wir dürfen auch vergessen, egal was die italienische Liga oder Sportgerichtsbarkeit entscheidet, es gibt ja auch immer noch DUEFA. Also am Ende sagt womöglich DUEFA, wegen Verstößen gegen das Financial Fair Play wird Juve nächstes Jahr nicht international spielen.
Also, ja.
Es ist, ich glaube, es sind alle Beteiligten dann irgendwann, es ist gut, wenn das Ding jetzt endgültig geregelt ist, weil, ja, braucht man nicht allzu häufig solche Geschichten.
Ja, es ist halt insofern absurd, weil ja quasi diese drei Punkte aus dem Epole-Spiel, die verloren gegangen sind, die verhindern ja, dass man doch noch sich sportlich hätte qualifizieren können.
Genau, du sagst das, weil vor allen Dingen schaut, dann gehen sie auf 62 und am Wochenende spielen sie gegen Milan. Die haben das direkte Duell da gehabt. Also dementsprechend, ja, es ist, nochmal.
Aber bleibt es jetzt bei den 10, das ist sicher?
Ja, Juvec kann logisch auch nochmal Rekurs einlegen, aber nochmal, es geht auch darum, es kann ja auch noch was anderes dazukommen. Also quasi, das ging ja nur erst mal unter Anführungszeichen um diese Bilanzfälschungsvorwürfe. Es gibt ja auch noch den Strang, wo Juve ja im Zuge der Corona-Krise sozusagen Zahlungen, Gehaltszahlungen einbehalten hat, das auch an die Börse kommuniziert hat. So, schau mal, wir haben uns mit den Spielern geeinigt, dass gewisse Gehälter, sozusagen Monatsgehälter, nicht ausgezahlt werden. Das wurde dann so verbrieft, auch in der Bilanz. Und dann kam raus, dass Juve aber, ja, persönliche Abmachungen mit Spielern hatte, dass die Gehälter dann doch irgendwie auf anderen Wegen lief. Und da gibt es eigentlich Beweise, schwarz auf weiß. Also ich glaube, dass Juve da auch nochmal ungemacht wurde. Also ich glaube, wir können uns jetzt sicher sein, Juve spielt nächstes Jahr 1000% keine Champions League. Das war für mich auch davor schon klar, weil wie gesagt auch die UEFA da das Auge drauf hätte. Ob sie überhaupt international spielen, vielleicht kommt jetzt sogar der Fall, dass die UEFA sie für ein Jahr sperrt und Juve dadurch jetzt gar nicht unfroh darüber ist, dass sie sich vielleicht sportlich für die Conference League oder Europa League qualifizieren würden. Dass sie da dann vielleicht dieses eine Jahr Sparer absitzen würden, um dann sozusagen wieder in Gang zu kommen. Das ist jetzt im Moment noch Spekulation, aber Juve in der Champions League wird nächstes Jahr nicht passieren.
Okay, so. Und dann haben wir noch ein Thema aus der Serie A und zwar völlig klar, ist ja logisch, der Meistertrainer, er muss weg, Napoli. Ich meine, wie haben die sich jetzt zur Meisterschaft geschleppt? Das war unwürdig.
Wie haben die sich präsentiert?
Die Menschen haben vor Trauer ihre blau-weißen Fahnen aus den Fenstern gehängt. Wochenlang.
Wahrscheinlich umgedreht.
Also Spalletti muss weg.
Ja, auch wieder eine dieser Geschichten. Also fangen wir mal an, in Neapol wird seit Wochen gefeiert. Die Stadt ist immer noch im Ausnahmezustand. Das ist ein einziges Freude pur. Jetzt am Wochenende gab es auch einen 3-1-Heimsieg gegen Inter. Der war insofern ganz, ja, was heißt, er hatte eine gewisse Bedeutung, denn dadurch hat Neapol jetzt alle 19 italienische Konkurrenten in dieser Saison geschlagen. Also Inter war die einzige Mannschaft, die sie noch nicht auf dem Weg zu diesem triumphalen Scudetto geschlagen haben. Das haben sie jetzt durch das 3-1 im Rückspiel. Genau, da haben sie jetzt auch den Haken dahinter gemacht. Also eigentlich könnte man meinen, alles wunderbar. Aber rund um dieses Inter-Spielen, das war wirklich großartig. Ich habe in die Pressekonferenz vor dem Spiel zweimal angeschaut. Es hat eine halbe Stunde gedauert. Und gefühlt würde ich sagen, um Inter ging es ungefähr 30 Sekunden. Denn es ist die Geschichte zwischen Luciano Spalletti, dem Trainer, und De Laurentiis, dem Präsidenten. Kurz die Fakten. De Laurentiis oder Verein hatte eine einseitige Option, den Vertrag mit Spalletti zu verlängern. Diese Option hat er gezogen, schon kurz nach dem Scudetto. Mitgeteilt wurde das Spalletti anscheinend über so eine... wie über ein Eileinschreiben im Prinzip. Über eine digitale Mitteilung. Das fand Spalletti anscheinend schon nicht mal so cool, dass das auf den Weg ablief. Aber eben Fakt ist, es hat sich gezeigt zwischen diesen zwei. Das sind wahnsinnig starke Charaktere. Und es hat schon während der Saison, es hat schon letzte Saison da ein bisschen gekrieselt. De Laurentiis ist, erinnern sich vielleicht ein paar, das ist ein Film-Macher, ein Kinoproduzent, einer, der die große Show liebt, einer, der weiß, wie er sich zu inszenieren hat. Nachzufragen bei Carlo Ancelotti, da gibt es auch, wie gesagt, große Namen der Vergangenheit, die auch gespürt haben, dass es nicht einfach ist mit diesen Präsidenten.
Hat sie jetzt auch mit der Liga angelegt und hat vorgeschlagen, wir sollten die TV-Rechte, die ausländischen TV-Rechte, alles selbst produzieren und dann einfach mit Netflix, HBO und so weiter das bei denen einspeisen.
Er hat viele Ideen. Es war wohl anscheinend so ein Burgfrieden über die ganze Saison. Sie haben es Gott sei Dank hinbekommen, das unter den Teppich zu belassen. De Laurentiis hatte eben gerade in den Jahren davor, auch immer wieder mal ist er während der Saison, ist es dann zu Äußerungen gekommen, die auch so ein bisschen die ganze Stabilität des Vereins ein bisschen ins Wankel gebracht hat. Dieses Jahr nicht. Also alles im Sinne der Mannschaft, alles im Sinne der Stadt, dass dieser 33-jährige Traum, der 33 Jahre lang gedauert hat, endlich wieder gelebt werden konnte. Aber jetzt kommt es halt anscheinend zutage. Spalletti hat auf der Pressekonferenz nur gesagt, ich habe mich vor einer Woche mit dem Präsidenten getroffen. Es ist alles klar. Aber der Präsident muss sagen, was Sache ist. Der Präsident sagt nichts, was Sache ist. Ich muss echt sagen, es ist der Stadt Neapel und auch den Fans gegenüber, finde ich, ein unwürdiges Schauspiel. Denn sowohl Spalletti als auch De Laurentis betonen ja immer wieder und auch völlig zurecht, dass dieser Verein so unglaublich von dieser Stadt, von diesen Menschen getragen wird. Und ich finde, ihnen gegenüber müsste man das anders lösen. Also es kann ja jeder seine Interessen haben. Es ist ja völlig in Ordnung, wenn De Laurentis andere Ideen hat. Wenn auch Spalletti, da kommen wir auch noch dazu, ich kann mir gut vorstellen, dass Spalletti ein Jahr Auszeit nimmt. Denn er hat jetzt auf der Pressekonferenz, wie ich finde, auch glaubhaft klar gemacht, hey, es gibt kein Angebot von anderen Vereinen, was ja manchmal kolportiert wurde. Er hat gesagt, ich will auch gar keine anderen Angebote hören. Also er hat so ein bisschen zwischen den Zeilen, glaube ich, klar gemacht, ich kann mir gut vorstellen, dass der jetzt einfach mal eine Auszeit nimmt, weil 2 Jahre...
Hoffentlich lernt er Deutsch.
Absolut, genau. Der nächste Marksmoor. Genau. Also das so viel dazu. Nochmal, Spalletti kann seine Motivationen haben, de Laurent ist alles gut, aber ich finde es den Menschen, die wirklich auch diesen Traum ja auch möglich gemacht haben, da wäre eine klare Ansage einfach. Die hätten es sich verdient, finde ich. Und jetzt wabert es rum und jetzt ist die große Frage, wird es am letzten Spieltag, wo ja die Meister, wo das Codetta auch überreicht wird, jetzt da dann offiziell gemacht. Vor dem Interspiel gab es jetzt so eine Szene, da gab es eine Prämierung vor dem Anpfiff, wo de Laurentis und Spalletti beide im Mittelkreis da waren. Und du hast fast das Gefühl gehabt, Spalletti hat auf jeden Fall darauf geachtet, dass immer ein paar Meter zwischen ihm waren. Also es ist halt einfach so schade, weil diese Mannschaft auch so einen überragenden Fußball gespielt hat. Und im Prinzip, so wie es jetzt aussieht, wird diese symbiose Spalletti-Mannschaft jetzt nach diesen zwei Jahren nicht mehr weitergehen. Noch mal, da kann jeder seine Gründe haben. Die können wir jetzt vielleicht nicht gut finden oder können wir auch nicht verstehen. Das finde ich ist nicht mein Punkt. Mein Punkt ist wirklich nur den Leuten gegenüber, den Neapolitanern, das Ganze halt einfach, hey, wenn die Entscheidung gefallen ist, sag den Leuten doch einfach was Sache ist.
Ja, vor allem klingt es ja so, als sei die Entscheidung gefallen.
Ja, es gibt logisch auch noch die Vermutungen, wo möglich probiert De Laurenti doch noch irgendwie alles in so einer spektakulären Kinoaktion dann am Ende doch noch Spalletti zu überzeugen.
Mit so Papiersche dann vor seine Tür, macht einen romantischen Musiker und dann...
Du, ich sage, gehört kein Inlass, sagt euch vielleicht noch was, ehemalige Schweizer Nationalspieler, als der nach Neapel kam, den hat De Laurenti mit einer Löwenmaske präsentiert. Kein Witz, einfach mal kurz danach googeln. Also nur um zu sagen, der Mann liebt die großen Auftritte und dementsprechend vielleicht hat er uns im Hinterkopf noch die Idee, dass der Spalletti doch überzeugen kann.
Es gibt doch immer diese Heiratsanträge im Stadion, bevor der Scudetto überreicht wird. Geht er auf die Knie und...
Wer weiß, ja. Wie gesagt, es ist insofern halt, weil es ist jetzt nicht nur die Figur Spalletti, es war davor eigentlich schon klar, Cristiano Giuntoli, das ist der Sportdirektor, der eigentlich diese Mannschaft auch über viele Jahre gebaut hat. Da heißt es eigentlich auch schon seit Wochen, dass er für sich eigentlich schon entschieden hat, dass seine Arbeit in Neapel beendet ist. Er ist als Juve anscheinend ganz, ganz heißer Kandidat. Also sollte jetzt Napoli wirklich Giuntoli plus Spalletti verlieren, dann ist das halt schon auch ein herber Schlag. Aber mal schauen, was der Laurent ist aus dem Hut. Da diskutieren ja schon viele, viele Namen logischerweise Richtung potenzielle Nachfolge. Luis Enrique ist im Moment ein sehr, sehr heißer Kandidat. Der wird in Italien im Moment fast als Nummer 1 Kandidat angesehen. Vincenzo Italiano gestern mit der Fiorentina eben. Für mich einer, der in den nächsten Jahren einen sehr, sehr guten Weg gehen wird. Der würde perfekt mit seinem 4-3-3 auch dazu passen. Der hat so einen ähnlichen Ansatz. Wie gesagt, wie viele Probleme er gestern interbereitet hat, das zeigt eben, wie viel Potenzial da drin steckt. Also es bleibt, es wird nicht langweilig, aber ich finde es echt schade, dass diese Geschichte, diese so großartige Fußballgeschichte, dann irgendwie anscheinend so zu Ende geht.
Aber ich gehe davon aus, das Umfeld Napolies nimmt das ruhig und besonders auf.
Ja, das ist auch besonders. Also wirklich diese Pressekonferenz, so schnell werde ich die nicht vergessen. Ich glaube, die vorletzte Frage, noch mal, es ging eine halbe Stunde, war dann irgendwann, zumindest dem Audio nach, auch von einem älteren Journalisten, also zumindest so hat man es, der glaube ich schon viel erlebt hat, der dann so angefangen hat mit, ja Herr Spalletti, ich glaube, ich muss es Ihnen nicht sagen, aber ich sage es Ihnen trotzdem mal, Sie wissen schon, dass Sie hier Legendenstatus in dieser Stadt haben. Diese Stadt wird Ihnen nie vergessen, was Sie in dieser Saison geleistet haben. Und deswegen habe ich jetzt eine Frage. Können Sie uns versprechen, dass Sie in den nächsten drei Jahren nicht zu Juventus wechseln? Also ja, da kann man jetzt logisch drüber lachen. Da gab es logisch auch, es gab leichtes Grinsen im Presseraum, aber das zeigt halt, wie diese Stadt, diesen Verein, diesen Fußball lebt, weil Juve ist halt sozusagen der große Anti-Figur. Und dann kommt einfach so eine Frage auch, und Spalletti muss der logisch auch schmunzeln.
Wollte man ihn nicht lieber dem Sportdirektor stellen?
Auch, aber das zeigt eben, wie besonders einfach der Fußball in Neapel gelebt wird. Und nochmal, jeder kann seine Entscheidung treffen. Vielleicht hat Spalletti auch schon vor währenden Wochen beschlossen, dass das für ihn einfach, das darf man vielleicht auch nicht vergessen, wie anspruchsvoll diese Arbeit da zwei Jahre in so einem emotionalen Umfeld sein muss. Wie viel dir das Kraft raubt, wie viel das Energie kostet. Spalletti hat auch mehrmals darauf hingewiesen. Ich habe 24 oder ich lebe 24, ich arbeite 24 Stunden für den Verein. Es gibt viele Berichte, wonach der tagelang in Castelvolturno im Sportzentrum auch übernachtet hat. Das ist so ein Perfektionist. Und dass so ein Umfeld dann, glaube ich, dir auch wahnsinnig viel Energie rauben kann, dass du vielleicht auch sagst, Spalletti ist jetzt auch nicht mehr die Jüngste, das dürfen wir auch nicht vergessen, vielleicht sagst du einfach, hey, ich kann euch nicht mehr geben. Das ist alles in Ordnung. Aber die Art und Weise, wie es jetzt eben auf offener Bühne ausgetragen wird, finde ich, wird dem Standort, wird dem Verein, wird den Neapolitanern nicht gerecht.
Ach ey, Funktionäre. Naja, so, das war ein langer erster Teil der Liga Tour. Ich bin selbst gespannt, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, wie viele Teile jetzt noch folgen werden. Wir werden es ja irgendwann gemeinsam herausgefunden haben. Jetzt danke ich euch erstmal bei Nils Kern vom Tikitaka-Fußball-Podcast und von Real total. Danke dir, lieber Nils, dass du mit dabei warst. Wenigstens du. Und herzlichen Dank an Christian Bernhard. Vielen Dank, dass du mit dabei warst. Jetzt brauchst du übrigens nicht mehr zu Twitter. Mast du Donnerst jetzt das neue Ding. Aber da kannst du jetzt wieder ein paar Jahre Zeit lassen.
Schauen wir mal, was dann passiert.
Schön, dass du hier warst.
Ja, vielen Dank. Großen Spaß gemacht.
Und hier geht es jetzt weiter mit, ja, lassen wir uns überraschen, also Uli Hebel und oder Alexis Menuge. Wir schauen einfach mal. Ich wünsche euch viel Spaß dabei. Und weiter geht's. Wir machen weiter mit Alexis Menuge. Ich freue mich sehr, dich zu sehen. Mehr noch als sonst, Alexis. Schön, dass du es trotz aller Probleme hierher geschafft hast. Na ganz so schlimm ist es nicht, wie beim FC Bayern, hätte ich jetzt gesagt. Das weiß ich streng von mir. Wir wollen über die Ligue 1 sprechen. Du hast uns da wie immer Themen mitgebracht. Und eins davon betrifft die Deutschen in der Ligue 1. Für die scheint es nicht so zu laufen. Was ist damit gemeint?
Und dass wir in der kommenden Saison keinen deutschen mehr haben werden in der Ligue 1. Außer einen, der zurückkommen muss. Nämlich Julian Draxler, der jetzt bei Benfica ausgeliehen war von Peugeot seit dem letzten Sommer. Aber Wetter überzeugen konnte. Dann war er seit Februar oder Januar sogar verletzt. Sodass er jetzt zurück muss nach Paris. Denn Peugeot hatte wieder mal eine geniale Idee, vor zwei Jahren mit ihm drei Jahre zu verlängern, obwohl er Dauerreservist war. Und ich bin sehr skeptisch, dass man für ihn schnell einen Abnehmer findet bis zum 1. September. Also bis der Transfermarkt schließt. Und dann könnte er wirklich, wenn er doch noch einen Verein finden sollte, der letzte deutsche Gewissens sein. Jérôme Boateng, nach zwei Jahren Olympique-Jung, gilt in Frankreich mittlerweile als einer der größten Flops der Geschichte, weil er für viel Geld kam, was sein Gehalt betrifft. 400.000 Euro im Monat für nichts. War jetzt immer auf der Bank, leicht verletzt, lustlos, bzw. hat ihn Trenado Romano nicht mal mehr zum Wamm machen geschickt. Also Sprichbände für seine Karriere. Jetzt habe ich kurz vor der Sendung eine Meldung gelesen, Boateng hat lukrative Angebote, aber es war Kevin Prinz, deswegen war ich kurz schockiert. Ja, war schon traurig, weil man hatte schon gewisse Hoffnungen, dass ein Weltmeister nach Jungwürzeln auch nicht alle Tage kommt. Der Deutsche hat einfach nie Fuss gefasst. Ich weiß nicht, was genau da passiert ist. Er hatte ja ein paar Probleme mit Mitspielern, das war mal sogar angreiflich, wie man hört. Er kam mit dem Akademie-Kettchen, war nicht so gut klar. Und jetzt ist man gespannt, womöglich wird er noch ein Abenteuer haben. USA oder Saudi-Arabien ist ja momentan in Mode. Aber auch er, wie gesagt, gehört zur Vergangenheit der Liga ein wenig gerade. Und dann haben wir natürlich Kevin Volland. Sein Vertrag läuft aus, Monaco ist auch nur noch dort Ersatzspieler seit zwei Jahren, seit eigentlich Niko Kovac weg ist. Auch er wird so fürs Mutum verlassen. Und natürlich unser Held, unser Idol, Alex Nübel, der mittlerweile so gut ist, dass Monaco ihn auch nicht mehr per Laie haben möchte. Und er wird auch erst einmal in München zurückkehren, Anfang Juli an der Säbener Straße, so mal zurück kennenlernen. Für wie lange sind wir gespannt. Aber klar, steht er auch dort und verkauft ihn und soll zurückkehren sehr schnell. Und wie gesagt, dann haben wir einen Deutschen mehr in der Liga. Und wie gesagt, das sind eigentlich fast nur Flugs gewesen. Das ist schon erstaunlich.
Steht in dahinter auch was Größeres? Weil auf der anderen Seite haben wir ja besonders viele französische Spiele in der Bundesliga seit ein paar Jahren.
Ja, 40. Und wenn du nicht nur in der Torschützenliste der Bundesliga hinschaust, unter den ersten fünf haben wir drei Franzosen. Polumony, Thuram und Neng Kun-Ku. Der womöglich ohne seine Verletzung sicherlich um die 25 bis 30 Treffer erzielt hatte. Und meiner Meinung nach wäre Leipzig sogar Meister geworden. Aber es ist eine andere Geschichte. Die Franzosen funktionieren richtig gut in der Bundesliga. Die jungen Franzosen insbesondere. Und ich glaube, die Sachen müssen sich fortsetzen, weil man sieht nicht viele in der deutschen Nachwuchs leider kommen in den nächsten Jahren. Wenn man so die Transfergerüchte hört, für diesen Sommer, dann gibt es wieder viele Franzosen, die in die Bundesliga wechseln werden. Und vielleicht werden wir die 50 vollmachen. Heuer 20 Franzosen in der Bundesliga. Und fast alle, nicht ganz, aber 70-80% der Franzosen setzen sich durch, sind glücklich, haben einen wichtigen Platz. Und dann können sie sich sehr schnell anpassen. Das erste Beispiel ist der kleine Manuel Cunel von Gladbach, der vor zwei Jahren komplett umgekommen war, und nach zwei Wochen, glaube ich damals nur, Adi Hüther sofort Stammenspieler war. Und dann auch unser Daniel Fakir und jetzt, wie viel Geld wechseln wird. Sie wissen, dass der Trainer nicht aufs Alter schaut in Deutschland, sondern aufs Talent, aufs Potenzial, auf die Mentalität. Und da sind die Franzosen gut aufgehoben. Und darüber freut sich insbesondere auch das Nationaltrainer Ligier de Jean, umso mehr. Seitdem schaut er sehr oft in die Bundesliga rüber und schaut sich die Spiele im Fernseher an bei Monaco.
Ja, ich meine, das ist natürlich auch so ein Ding, was parallel läuft. Also wir wissen, dass der französische Nachwuchs gerade besonders gut ist. Und das bedeutet zum einen, dass solche Spieler dann auch in die Bundesliga kommen. Und gleichzeitig wird ja vielleicht auch dann der Platz in der Ligue 1 generell für Spieler aus anderen Ländern enger. Oder betrifft das jetzt nur Deutschland?
Das ist ja ein historischer Verein von drei. Er war ja in den 60er Jahren zweimal im Oberbocker des Landesmeisters, Endspiel. Damals haben wir ihn real verloren. Und die waren auch mal ein paar Jahre weg vom Fenster. 3. Liga, 4. Und seit acht Jahren, glaube ich, sind wir jetzt in der Ligue 1. Haben sich dort etabliert. Und sie setzen vermehrt auf junge Spieler statt erfahrene, die aber von der Ligue 1 keine Ahnung haben. Die setzen lieber auf die Karte Jugend, weil es billiger ist. Und zweitens, weil man weiß, das Risiko ist geringer, dass ein junger Spieler aus dem eigenen Nachwuchs ein Flop wird, als einer, der aus Serbien oder Afrika oder Südamerika kommt, der wahrscheinlich eine gewisse Anpassungszeit benötigt und dann schon wieder verkauft wird. Weil heute dieses Geschäft wahnsinnig schnelllebig ist. Und auf der anderen Seite sind diese Spieler oder diese Vereine sehr schnell von englischen Vereinen kontaktiert, um diese jungen Spieler zu bepflichten. Die Eintracht hat da wirklich tolle Scouts, weil sie sehr schnell Top-Talente entdecken, die schon wie erst 2016, 2017 sind. Bei Herbie Leipzig ist das nicht anders. Da müssen sie noch mehr kämpfen. Wenn es diese Nabu-Snack nicht geben würde in Frankreich, dann wäre die Liga natürlich nicht mehr konkurrenzfähig. Sie ist eh schon nicht mehr so wie früher. Übrigens, wie Feier und Morgen, Max, 40. Geburtstag, nein, 30. Geburtstag, und Olympique Marseille, der einzige französische Verein, die jemals die Champions League gewann. Die Münchner Olympiastadion.
Mit Rudi Völler.
Auf Olympiastadion morgen ist Bastiz kurzendurch.
Ja, sehr gut. Und wer sich dafür interessiert, du warst im Nachholspiel-Podcast genau zu dieser Partie und hast ein bisschen erzählt, wie auch PSG-Fans dieses Finale verfolgt haben. Ich sag mal so, ähnlich wie 60er damals das Finale zu Hause verfolgt haben. Nur mit anderem Ausgang. Das scheint so zu sein. Wir hatten das heute auch schon mit Napoli und Juwel hier in dieser Sendung. Das scheint ein roter Faden zu werden. Also für die Deutschen läuft es nicht gut. In der Liga ist es also komplett überraschend, wenn man die letzten Ligaturen gehört hat. Dann würdest du gerne noch mir etwas von Nizza erzählen. Was ist denn bei Nizza los? Ich schaue auf die Tabelle und sehe 9. Tabellenplatz. 52 Punkte, damit ist man im Grunde raus aus allem. Nach unten hin kann nichts mehr passieren, nach oben hin sowieso gar nichts mehr. In der Liga sind ja nur noch zwei Spieltage zu spielen. Wie geht es da weiter?
Wir hatten das Thema Nizza zu Beginn der Saison, zumindest in der Hinrunde, noch vor der WM, dass die Mannschaften gekommen ist, dass Ineos, der Eigentümer aus England, richtig Geld investieren will und eine schlagkräftige Truppe aufbauen möchte. Die Bilanz nach dieser Saison ist grauenhaft. Man hat Lucien Favre entlassen, weil er mit dem Kader nicht zurecht kam, weil er auch bei den Transfers wenig zu sagen hatte. Nur Spieler, die er gar nicht haben wollte, wie Aaron Ramsey zum Beispiel, wie Rose Bartley oder auch Haspa Schmeichel. Du hast schon einige gute Namen in der Mannschaft. Aber was ist das für ein Projekt? Wohin wollen die Engländer, die mit aller Marktgerade Manchester United zu kaufen? Aber mit Kader haben sie einen riesen Konkurrenten. Und auch da wird es davon abhängen, sollte Ineos bei Menyoo ansteigen. Dann, was passiert mit Nizza, hatte noch das Kapitel, das auch noch Schatten geworfen hat auf diesen Verein mit Christophe Galtier, der jetzige PSG-Trainer, der letztes Jahr noch in Nizza war. Und der Rassismus vorgeworfen wurde, als er noch in Nizza war. Weil er hätte sich beklagt, weil es alles konditionell. Die Justiz ermittelt gerade noch. Alle wurden verhört bis auf Galtier. Wahrscheinlich warten die bis Samstag, bis sie Meister werden, offiziell. Da muss er auch ran. Aber er hätte sich beklagt, dass seine Kabine, es gibt einfach zu viele Muslime, und wenn der Ramadan kommt, dann hat er fast keine Spieler mehr, oder keine Fitenspieler mehr. Jeden Freitag mutten die in die Moschee, und das hat ihm auch nicht gepasst. Also immer wieder Vorwürfe, die natürlich im Schatten auf den Verein geworfen haben. Dann hast du natürlich diese Tittere aus, die Telefinale Deconferenz League gegen Null, bei dem FC Basel, obwohl du eine Riesenchance hattest, in diesem Wettbewerb sehr weit zu kommen. Also nur negative Sachen, und man weiß nicht, mit welchem Trainer man in die neue Saison geht, obwohl Ryan Potter ganz große Favorit ist. Er soll wirklich kommen, aber erst einmal will man diese Saison abschließen. Man hat noch zwei Spiele gegen Van Rijk bis zum 3. Juni. Dann wird wieder die letzte Saison schon aufgeräumt oder ausgeräumt, und dann wird auch ein neuer Kader gebastelt. Der einzige, der natürlich übrig bleibt, ist Dantzsch Bonfin. Er hat den Champions-League-Sieg vor zehn Jahren mit den FC Bayern verlängert. Der 40-jährige Brasilianer oder bald 40-jährige, ist der einzige Lichtblick in dieser Mannschaft, sogar bei diesem Verein.
Ach, der gute alte Dante. Das waren noch Zeiten. Das mit Luce Favre ist ja auch noch mal so eine Geschichte, die vielleicht so ein bisschen untergegangen ist. Weil, ich weiß noch, wir haben am 13. September zum Beispiel über Nizza gesprochen, in der Ligatur von damals. Da hast du ja noch mal erzählt, dass er sich eigentlich mit Lappach schon einig gewesen sein soll und dann von Nizza überzeugt wurde. Und dann ging das jetzt innerhalb von einem Dreivierteljahr so dahin. Wie würdest du denn jetzt seine Zeit da bewerten? Und gibt es denn darüber Erkenntnisse, wie es für Favre jetzt weitergehen könnte?
Ich bin sehr eng mit ihm. Er hat mich mal angerufen vor drei, vier Wochen, als es bei den Bayern sehr schlecht lief, weil wir wissen, was in München los ist. Das war so ein Teamgespräch. Aber dass ich ihn speziell dann frage, was war los mit Nizza? Da kommt natürlich nichts raus.
War das noch vor Tuchel? Also wollte er den Job von Nagelsmann?
Er wollte den Job schon vor einigen Jahren. Weil als Karl-Heinz Rummenigge noch der Präsident war, war er damals bei Serben Gelb als Spieler in Serben Zimmer, wie Kalle, und die haben sich richtig gut verstanden. Ich glaube, wo es damals bei Favres so gut lief, bei Gladbach und bei Slomgen in Hannover, waren beide sogar im Gespräch beim FC Bayern. Und da hat Lülü davon geträumt. Aber als das Angebot von Dortmund kam, dann, wo er noch in Nizza war, beim ersten Nizza-Abenteuer, hat er mir damals die SMS von Waxe gezeigt. Und da hat er sich sehr gefreut, dass Dortmund ihn haben will. Und danach, nach einer halben Jahre, hat er natürlich eine ganz andere Meinung über den BVB, wie es dann liegt mit ihm. Ich glaube, er ist jetzt weit über 60 und merkt immer mehr, wie schwer es ist, mit dem neuen Spielergeneration klarzukommen. Tatsächlich, mit der neuen Mentalität entwickelt sich alles weiter. Und er gehört einfach an eine andere Generation. Ich glaube, das wird ihm auch immer sicherer. Er hat noch nicht ganz abgegeben. Vielleicht reist ihm ein letztes Abenteuer. Aber ich würde auch nicht erstaunt sein oder überrascht sein, wenn wir demnächst die Meldung bekommen, er beendet seine Karriere. Er merkt auch, dass es schwierig ist. Bei Nils wird gesagt, da wurden Versprechungen gegeben, die nie angehalten wurden, von den Vereinserobungen. Da hat man das Problem, dass die Eigentümer aus England, die Neos, die ehemaligen Favres-Ligen noch aktiv sind bei Nizza. Favre hat eine Spielerliste gegeben, die Engländer wollten andere Spieler vorgeben oder eine Liste. Und der, damit nichts anfangen lässt, hat Favre sehr schnell aufgegeben. Und von sich aus nicht dazutreten, er wollte es, klar, aber er hat die ganze Hinrunde mit viel Distanz genommen. Er hat sich nicht mehr so viel Sorgen gemacht, wie man ihn eigentlich kennt. Hatte eigentlich den Kopf schon abgeschaltet und hat nur noch gewartet, dass er entlassen wird. Ich hatte auch mal am Telefon im September, wo es schon hieß, er wird ausgeworfen. Und damals hatte ich schon das Gefühl am Telefon, dass er nicht darauf wartet, aber dass er weiß, dass seine Tage gezählt sind und dass er sich da keine großen Illusionen macht. Also eigentlich war es ein trauriges, gleiche Rende für ihn, weil er tolle Arbeit geleistet hatte bei seinem ersten Abenteuer in Nizza, aber gab es auch sowieso. Aber er hatte einiges mit Kölb, wie er gewinnt ist. Aber irgendwann ist vorbei und ich befürchte, das war es für ihn.
Ich könnte ihn mir sehr gut als TV-Experten vorstellen. Er erklärt ja so gerne Fußball und hat eine sehr nette und sympathische Art. Oder kann er nicht die Trainer-Ausbildung beim DFB noch ein bisschen besser machen? Das könnte doch auch was sein. Ja, schreib es ihm doch einfach mal. Oder ich schreibe ihm die SMS, die zeigt er dir dann aber nicht erfreut, sondern, wer ist denn der Typ? Was soll denn das auf einmal? Also, lose your Fabri, dann schauen wir doch mal. Vielleicht sind ja auch die Härter-Verantwortlichen gerade ein bisschen hellhörig geworden. Mensch, da könnten wir doch auch nochmal eine Geschichte schreiben. Es scheint ja irgendwie alles schon wieder da. Aber das sind andere Themen. Ganz kurz, letzte Frage. Also, jetzt ist ja die Saison so gut wie vorbei. Gibt es noch irgendwas, was du ganz überraschend findest? Ich meine, es gibt ja auch noch das Rennen zwischen Rennes und Lille um den fünften Tabellenplatz. Also der Theorie nach auch noch mit Monaco, aber die sind schon drei Punkte weg bei noch sechs vergebenen Punkten. Aber es gibt ja noch was, was auszuspielen ist, plus der Abstiegskampf.
Monaco spielt in Rennes am Samstag. Okay, siehst du, habe ich gleich gesehen. Weil die Tor-Differenz deutlich schlechter als Rennes ist. Das heißt, wäre ich nicht verwundert, wenn Monaco in Zentralen sechst da ist, und es jetzt ja gar nicht europäisch dabei ist. Die Mannschaft ist gerade auf einem abstandenen Ast mit Trainer Philipp Clément, der auch in Frage gestellt wird. Übrigens posiert der Name Matthias Reis-Lehrer seit heute Morgen am Fürstentum. Und man weiß, dass die Verantwortlichen da immer gerne nach Deutschland chillen. Das haben wir in Kokovac gesehen. Aber das ist etwas wirklich Interessantes bei der Ligue 1-Konferenz am Samstagabend. Was passiert in Monaco, in Rennes. Aber es speckt auch an Lens. Fester zweiter, 2,2 Punkte im Durchschnitt bei diesem 10. Budget der Ligue 1. Eine sehr sympathische Mannschaft. Die Kollegen haben gesagt, es ist die einzige Mannschaft, wo die Spieler auf dem Platz lächeln.
Das sagt auch viel über die ganze Liga aus. Alexi, ich danke dir sehr, sehr herzlich. Und wir werden uns ja, wenn alles gut geht, dann ja vielleicht sogar in Person in diesem Jahr noch einmal hören zu Ligatür. Also in dieser Saison. In diesem Jahr hoffentlich noch ganz viel. Als der letzte. Genau, sehr gut. Jetzt ist der Druck da. Jetzt kennen die Hörerinnen und Hörer den Aufnahmetermin. Danke dir, Alexi. Bis bald mal wieder. Uli Hebel ist jetzt hier, Uli. Ich freue mich sehr, dich zu hören und dich zu sehen.
Mir geht es genauso.
Das ist doch schön. Wir wollen sprechen über die Premier League. Das kommt jetzt wahrscheinlich so überraschend, dadurch, dass du hier bist. Und da müssen wir natürlich einmal kurz über den feststehenden Meister sprechen. City hat es geschafft. Und mit was für einem effizienten Ressourceneinsatz, möchte ich sagen.
Ja, es war dann am Ende fast zu erwarten, irgendwie. Clary Neville hat das relativ schön gesagt. Ich glaube, im Januar, am Ende wird City dann doch wieder mit 10 Punkten Vorsprung Meister. Da habe ich nur ein bisschen gelächelt. Aber ja, die sind schon anderswo unterwegs, wenn sie eine normale Form haben. Das, glaube ich, muss man neidlos anerkennen. Da gibt es ja Gründe dafür, die man mal ausgebreitet und diskutiert, mal weniger ausgebreitet, aber rein sportlich betrachtet, wenn das zulässig ist, ist das schon wow.
Ja, und ich meine, da kann auch jeder so seine eigene Meinung haben zu City. Ich habe da eine Meinung, bzw. ich habe da ein Gefühl. Also ich spüre eben, dass ich mich mit City nicht so mitfreue. Und das hängt halt mit dem ganzen Drumherum zusammen. Aber ich glaube, das ist was sehr Subjektives, was wir hier auch schon oft genug thematisiert haben. Was wir uns aber noch nicht besprochen haben, beim letzten Mal, als es nach dem Arsenal-Spiel ja eigentlich auch schon mehr oder weniger fest stand, dass es City werden würde. Ist das ein Problem für die Liga, dass jetzt zum fünften Mal innerhalb von sechs Jahren derselbe Meister, das sind ja fast Bundesliga-Verhältnisse? Und das ist ja das große Schreckgespräch in Europa.
Ja, es wird auch tatsächlich viel diskutiert auf der Insel. Das kenne ich so gar nicht, dass man sich solche Gedanken über die Liga macht, also wirklich so übergeordnete und dann auch langweilige Themen. Weil zumindest war es ja in den letzten Jahren so, dass Liverpool als großer Gegner Cities ganz lange mit dabei war immer, die jetzt aber so aussehen, als gehen sie in eine Art von Rebuild. Und Arsenal traut man es noch nicht so ganz zu, dass die jetzt wirklich der lange Rivale sein könnten. Ich glaube, vorher hat man sich deshalb nicht so richtig viele Gedanken gemacht. Und davor, also bevor Guardiola in die Liga kam, bringen wir es auf den Punkt, gab es das ja nicht. Weil selbst wenn es mal ein 3-Peat gab, es gab schon Manchester United-Zeiten unter Sir Alex Ferguson oder dann auch mal Arsenal kurzzeitig, die so eine leichte Vormachtstellung hatten. Aber sowas gab es noch nie. Und die Engländer haben wirklich große Angst um ihre Liga. Und ich meine, jetzt kann man das Argument nicht bringen, wie in Deutschland, dass das ein Finanzvorsprung ist. Ja, der ist es, minimal, aber natürlich nicht bei weitem in der Größenordnung. Das heißt, wie sollen es denn die anderen machen, wenn City so gut arbeitet? Weil das ist ja das eine. Also die Mittelherkunft, darüber müssen wir sprechen. Auch wenn irgendwann mal am 10. Juni alles gesagt und getan ist und das reichen sollte. Und dann ist es möglicherweise tatsächlich die beste Saison einer englischen Mannschaft ever. Dann muss man speziell über die Mittelherkunft reden, aber den Mitteleinsatz, über den muss man halt auch reden. Der sucht seinesgleichen. Jemals, glaube ich, in der Fußballwelt. Weil was Guardiola nichtsdestotrotz daraus gemacht hat, ist natürlich Wahnsinn.
Ja, und das ist ja auch interessant, weil hier ja die Diskussion so geführt wird. Ohne Investoren kriegen wir nie wieder Spannung. Und jetzt haben wir hier die Investorenliga im Weltfußball. Und da gibt es eben auch Konstellationen, in denen die Spannung weg ist. Vielleicht ist es aber für andere leichter, die Lücke zu schließen. Und das hängt dann mehr von der Verwendung, von dem Einsatz der Mittel ab. Was uns ja vielleicht auch halbwegs elegant zu Newcastle United bringt. Die jetzt die Champions League sicher gemacht haben. Und da muss man glaube ich, bevor man da auch nochmal übers Drum herum spricht, erstmal das sportlich einordnen. Kannst du noch mal kurz ein Bild zeichnen? Es ist ein Bild in vielen Grautönen und jetzt aber sehr viel Farbe, was Newcastle eigentlich so jetzt in den letzten Jahren durchgemacht hat. Grau hast du recht.
Ich bin ja in Weiß und Schwarz. Also es ist, ich glaube, das eine Ding, was wir alle vor Augen haben, ist natürlich der Übernahme-Deal, der auch lange gedauert hat von Saudi-Arabien, damals von Mike Ashley. Und jetzt sind sie in saudi-arabischer Hand, das ist ein Staatsfonds, aber davor war es Mike Ashley, der eine Sportartikel-Verkaufskette hat sozusagen, also einen Discounter, der überall in England ist, inzwischen auch in Deutschland im Übrigen. Und der Typ hatte Newcastle sich aus einem Grund zugelegt, also erstmal zu prallen, ganz, ganz, ganz zu Beginn. Das ist aber dann relativ schnell weggegangen. Dann ging es irgendwann in die Richtung, dass der zum Beispiel den St. James Park mit diesen Namensrechten versehen hat, was überhaupt nicht gut ankam und was dann selbst er gemerkt hat, dass es nicht geht. Und irgendwann hat der nur noch Geld rausgezogen für sich und hat überhaupt gar nichts mehr reingegeben und hat die wirklich fast ausbluten lassen. Also der Verein war, er hat nichts mehr gekauft, er hat einen total verwahrlosten maroden Kader hinterlassen, dann hat er doch mal wieder vereinzelt was reingegeben, damit sie nicht absteigen, hat entsprechende Trainerentscheidungen getroffen und es war wurscht unterm Strich. Also Newcastle hat gar keinen Ausschlag gemacht in die eine oder andere Richtung. Sie sind inzwischen mal abgestiegen. Ja, mein Gott, war halt so. Hat sich auch so ein bisschen der tristen Umgebung, in der der Verein ja reingeboren wurde und diese Region wurde immer trister politisch gesehen. Das heißt, hat sich ganz gut angepasst. Das war irgendwie der Verein der Abgehängten sozusagen. Und das ist, glaube ich, mit auch ein Grund, warum die Menschen jetzt überhaupt gar nicht nachdenken wollen. Die sind überhaupt nicht bereit dazu, die Dimension ihrer Besitzer erkennen zu wollen. Es ist ihnen wurscht, weil endlich wieder jemand sich um die Region schert, endlich wieder Geld reingibt und endlich wieder das Wichtigste, was sie haben, nämlich Newcastle United und den Fußball, florieren lassen und jetzt spielen die Champions League. Und das ist, glaube ich, der Grund, warum das vergleichsweise unkritisch gesehen wird. Also dass jetzt mal in total schneller Raffung erklärt, was da alles passiert ist.
Ja, dazu muss man eben sagen, dass Newcastle immer wieder einzelne Hochphasen hatte, aber eben dieses wir rutschen ins Mittelfeld ab, vielleicht sogar in die 2. Liga und dann kommen wir wieder hoch. Da gab es immer mal wieder aber allein die Träne, die man hatte. Also eine der Hochphasen war unter Kevin Keegan, eine unter Sir Bobby Robson, das ist auch glaube ich die noch, an die sich die Älteren von uns noch erinnern. Das war Anfang der 2000er, wo man eben immer unter den ersten 5 mit dabei war. Dann der Abstieg mit Alan Shearer ja noch, irgendwie so als letzter Kanone, Patrone wollte ich sagen. Und Rafa Benitez war da auch Trainer, aber da haben wir eben schon erlebt, da war ja ein Aufstieg mit dabei und das war ja das Newcastle, was wir jetzt in den letzten 10 Jahren erlebt haben. Irgendwas zwischen Platz 10 und 15 oder vielleicht auch mal ein Abstieg. Und das ist halt jetzt mit der Champions League beendet.
Genau, sie sind wieder da, wo sie damals sozusagen aufgehört haben, als du jetzt begonnen hast. Das ist ja nochmal ein Zeitstrahl 10 Jahre davor gewissermaßen. Und das war ja dann das Hässliche, weil man dachte, mit Mike Ashley kommt jemand, der irgendwie vom Fach ist und der wahrscheinlich ein gewisses Interesse hat, dass Newcastle weiter floriert, um ja auch seine Marke dann zu transportieren. Der hat aber aus rein wirtschaftlichen Gesichtspunkten und rein egomanen Gesichtspunkten gehandelt. Dem ging es niemals um Newcastle United und schon überhaupt kein Stück um die, die den Eintritt da bezahlen fürs Fußballspiel. Und das ist dann sozusagen die neuere Newcastle-Zeit, die sich wahrscheinlich deshalb alleine bei mir so breit gemacht hat, weil die Zeit so lange ging und die war so langweilig. Die war so sterbenslangweilig, weil wir immer wieder das Gleiche erzählt haben. Und immer wieder gesagt, boah, Mike Ashley und niemand hatte irgendwie mehr irgendwas übrig für den Verein, außer die, die ja dafür verantwortlich sind, dass der Verein in der Größenordnung da ist. Nämlich eben die, die Eintritt bezahlen. Und es war eine Zeit lang hands down nichts anderes als Eintritt bezahlen für Newcastle United.
Ja, und gleichzeitig ist es ein total interessantes Beispiel dafür, sowohl wie die Liga mit ebenso Investoren umgeht und wie dann auch so Investoren sich in den Fußball rein sneaken, trotz Financial Fair Play und so. Das müssen wir jetzt nicht im Detail ausführen. Aber der Fonds, der übernommen hat, gehört ja zu 80% Saudi-Arabien. Und die Liga hat sich durchaus auf dieses Argument zurückgezogen, weil jede Übernahme muss ja überprüft werden. Und gerade im United Kingdom sieht man Saudi-Arabien, glaube ich, rund um die Ermordung des Journalisten, was ja, jetzt habe ich den Namen gerade vergessen, Khashoggi. Glaube ich noch mal ein bisschen kritischer, weil man da direkt mit involviert war. Und das hat die Liga aber dann durchgewunken, hat gesagt, naja, so viel Saudi-Arabien ist das doch gar nicht usw. Ich paraphrasiere jetzt. Und jetzt gibt es eben die Gerüchte, ja, Saudi-Arabien, oder natürlich ein Unternehmen aus Saudi-Arabien soll neuer Hauptsponsor werden. Das ist eben genau der Weg, mit dem man dann eben Financial Fair Play-Regularien einhalten kann, weil man dann eben sagt, ja, Moment mal, wir haben die Kohle ja nicht vom Investor bekommen, sondern von unserem Hauptsponsor, dass der zufällig, wirklich nur rein zufällig mit dem Investor zu tun hat. Das wissen wir ja nicht. Das ist quasi das Manchester City-Modell, das ist das PSG-Modell, das Virtus, das Newcastle-Modell. So funktioniert das trotz Financial Fair Play, dass ein Investor eben reinkommt in einen Verein und dann auch an europäischen Wettbewerben teilnehmen darf.
Die grün-weißen Trikots im Übrigen sind auch. Es hat sich halt ein Designer überlegt, dass das zufällig Saudi-Arabiens Jarts-Farben sind.
Ja, da sehe ich jetzt auch hin. Da wollen wir jetzt auch nicht überkritisch sein. Aber gut, das ist all das. Newcastle hat es auf jeden Fall geschafft, die Champions-League zu machen.
Aber ein Satz vielleicht zum Sportlichen. Das ist potenziell der reichste Club, den es gibt. Ich glaube, da gibt es ja gar keinen Deckel. Also, wenn die wollten, könnten die machen, was sie wollen. Nur zur Ehrenrettung, Eddie House, der ist natürlich auch auf einer anderen Seite ein bisschen problematisch, der will davon halt auch gar nichts wissen. Wird auf der Pressekonferenz immer mal wieder angesprochen. Jetzt hat sich langsam etwas beruhigt, aber es gibt immer mal wieder die Fragen, wenn es dann die originalen El Plasticos gibt. Also das originale Sportswashing-Modell, Chelsea zum Beispiel gegen Newcastle, da ist das ein großes Thema gewesen und eigentlich auch ausschließlich das auf den Pressekonferenzen. Wenn der gefragt wird, will er halt so gar nichts davon wissen, was natürlich immer ein netter Trick ist, sich der ganzen Verantwortung zu entziehen, aber das, was Newcastle seit Übernahme ausgegeben hat für Spielertransfers, das, was dahinter steht, weiß man nur zum Teil, aber auch das hält sich einigermaßen so die Waage zu dem, was für Premier League-Verhältnisse normal ist. Aber was die an Transfers ausgegeben haben seither, könnte sich ein Premier Leagueist mit der Ligenzugehörigkeit in der Dauer wie Newcastle auch so leisten. Das heißt, das ist jetzt nichts, die haben jetzt nicht wie damals Manchester City begonnen, Rubinho zu holen, von Real Madrid und Joe, von Palmeiras für 180.000 Millionen und noch, weiß ich nicht, 20 andere Spieler, die extrem viel groß gekommen sind, die haben wirklich sinnvoll dazugekauft. Und das Fußball-Team als solches macht wirklich Spaß. Es ist gut organisiert, es ist ein sehr physisches. Also der Vergleich, den ich mal bei uns im Podcast genannt habe, zu dem stehe ich und der, glaube ich, fasst ganz gut zusammen. Das ist Liverpool der frühen Kloppzeit. 16, 17, 17, 18. Genau so spielen die. Total unangenehm physisch, wahnsinnig gut eingestellt. Die haben eine Gruppe zusammengestellt von Typen, die ausnahmslos wissen, wann sie ins Pressing gehen, die in dem Punkt wahnsinnig unangenehm sind, die also in erster Linie arbeiten, arbeiten, arbeiten. Und dann haben sie noch einen Bruno Gimaraes dazu addiert, der das Fußballerische löst. An Joel Linton von Mittelstürmer auf 6 auf 8 umgebaut, funktioniert plötzlich sehr gut. Das ist eine Eddie-How-Sache gewesen. Das muss man denen schon lassen, auch da wieder. Das ist das eine, der ganze Teil, der dahinter steckt. Das andere ist die sportliche Entwicklung. Und Eddie How hat auf 20 übernommen und führt sich in die Champions League innerhalb von 1,5 Jahren. Da ist nicht das ganz große Investment dabei. Vielleicht wäre Regimara es da nicht hingegangen. Kann sein, wenn Saudi-Arabien im Hintergrund nicht gäbe. Vielleicht sind da auch Handgelder geflossen, von denen wir noch nicht wissen. Möglich, aber ich behaupte, so einen Spieler in dem Kaliber, den kann man sich auch mal holen, wenn man einfach 6 Jahre in der Premier League dabei ist. Oder einfach Nothing in Forest ist und es trotzdem macht.
Genau auf die wollte ich jetzt kommen. Das ist super, weil über die will ich nämlich jetzt in dem Zusammenhang auch kurz sprechen. Die haben ja 41 Neuzugänge gehabt. Die haben quasi vom Transfer Saldo her hinter Chelsea und United. Chelsea spielt in der kompletten eigenen Liga, wissen wir auch die Geschichte dazu, United sowieso. Aber dann kommt schon Nottingham Forest, die quasi im Saldo am meisten investiert haben. Und die haben jetzt aber dann doch den Klassenerhalt sicher gemacht. Die sind jetzt safe, 6 Punkte vor Leicester. Es ist ja jetzt nur noch ein Spieltag. Ist da jetzt alles aufgegangen? Ja, es ist ja ein bisschen belächelt worden. Zumindest aus Deutschland heraus, weil da eben auch so mancher deutscher Spieler für viel Geld hingeht.
Ja, und es ist ja tatsächlich so gewesen, dass Steve Cooper im Januar-Fans dann nochmal gesagt hat, bitte nicht so viel machen. Was auch erstaunlich ist für einen Trainer, weil der Besitzer da, Evangelos Malenakis...
Ich bin nicht so gut mit Namen, bitte keine Neuzugänge wäre.
Und der hat immer noch dazu... Also wenn man den jetzt nicht vor Augen hat, dann sollte man sich den parallel mal irgendwie auf einem Endgerät aufrufen. Der hat noch so einen leicht traurigen, in Bayern sagt man mirselsichtigen Gesichtsausdruck. Das heißt, man kann sich das ganz gut vorstellen, wie das wirklich lief, bei dem er das gemacht hat. Also da ist ein Schiffsmagnat aus Griechenland am Ruder, Evangelos Malenakis, der auch Olympiakos besitzt noch. Und der hat schon immer angekündigt in der ganzen Zeit bei Nottingham Forest, ich bring die wieder auf das Niveau damals, wie unter Klaff, und das ist auch der Grund, warum ich die geholt habe. Und wenn wir mal aufgestiegen sind, dann investiere ich mal richtig. Also der hatte, und der hat sich jetzt auch noch mal in einem Interview gezeigt, nach geschafftem Klassenerhalt, nach Sieg gegen Arsenal. Und man merkt, dass der das durchaus auch zu Selbstverwirklichungszwecken macht. Also da steckt jetzt nicht unbedingt ausschließlich eine Kaderbau-Idee dahinter. Wenngleich auch da, das hat auf eine weise Tradition, in den letzten Championship-Jahren war das immer so, dass die immer um die 20 Transfers gemacht haben, rein und so um die 10 raus. Merkt man auch schon, das geht nicht gut auf, wenn man das einfach 6 Jahre lang durchzieht. Die hatten teilweise bis zu 50 Spieler zu Beginn der Saison im Kader, haben ganz oft einen Manager gesucht und jetzt haben sie einen Trainer bekommen. Und das war das größte Glück in der Geschichte des Vereins, dass die Steve Cooper genommen hatten, letztes Jahr dann im Winter aufgestiegen sind und der das irgendwie alles managt. Alleine deshalb, weil es ist ja unmöglich, dass so viele verschiedene Nationen, die allesamt nie in der Premier League gespielt haben, es ist ja kaum einer dabei, von den Neuzugängen, der jemals Premier League gespielt hat. Und wenn man die Liga kennt, weiß man, wie wichtig das ist, dass man sich da einigermaßen einruft. Ist Steve Cooper für mich ein Manager of the Year Kandidat? Also der steht mindestens im Halbfinale, weil das Erstaunliche ist, was der geleistet hat. Das ist kein schöner Fußball gewesen, das war immer das passivste 451, was du dir vorstellen kannst. Aber ich habe jegliches Verständnis dafür, dass er es so macht, weil das ist das Einfachste, was du denen beibringen kannst, das Zentrum zu machen und nicht irgendwie besondere Dinge wollen. Und dann gab es halt ein, zwei Ausreiser nach oben. Ich hatte oft zu vielen, vielen verschiedenen Zeitpunkten echt Angst um die, weil die nicht gut aussahen. Und dann kam aber wieder mal eine Phase von Brandon Johnson, der echt gut aussah. Und dann wieder mal eine Phase von Ryan Yates, witzigerweise die, die nicht neu verpflichtet wurden. Und dann jetzt zum Schluss, morgen gibt es White. Das war ja so der Transfer. Einer, zwei aus der Premier League, aber wo alle gesagt haben, jetzt ist ein kompletter Dachstuhl abgebrannt. Die holen den Ersatzspieler von den Wolverine Wanderers für so viel Geld und was soll das überhaupt? Aber Cooper kannte den zusammen, er ist Joujon-Weltmeister geworden mit ihm und wusste, dass das der Typ ist, der für dieses System wichtig sein wird.
Und so hat es Nottingham tatsächlich geschafft, in der Liga zu bleiben. Und in die Liga hinein möchten zwei Teams, Coventry und Luton, das, wie wird es immer genannt, das teuerste Fußballspiel, also das Spiel, in dem so meisten Geld geht. Wer steigt auf in die Premier League, der bekommt richtig, richtig viel Kohle. Da willst du mit uns noch drauf vorausblicken, denn das ist eigentlich so das Match to watch jetzt.
Das ist das, was Fußball auch kann, auch der moderne Fußballer auch kann. Wir sind in 2023, du sagst schon, richest game of football. Das heißt, wenn das Team, das dann hochkommt, einmal die Klasse hält, haben sie mindestens 300 Millionen Pfund alleine an Fernsehgeldern eingesackt. Da sind wir noch nicht bei Sponsoring und so. Und normalerweise würde man jetzt denken, gut, das treibt alles auf die Spitze, dieses eine Spiel. Das Schöne ist, diesmal sind es zwei Teams gegeneinander, zwei Vereine gegeneinander, die das romantisch machen, auf eine Weise, weil sie es so lange in Anlauf genommen haben, um da dabei zu sein, weil die beiden Teams so viel erlebt haben in ihren Vereinsgeschichten, jetzt auch neuerlich in den Vereinsgeschichten, dass das ein Spiel für die Fans ist tatsächlich. Und ich glaube sogar auch für die Neutralen. Also klar, die Fanlager wissen jeweils, das ist das wichtigste Spiel der Vereinsgeschichte, weil wenn wir das haben, dann werden wir für immer anders dastehen. Aber auch für neutrale Menschen, da gibt es so viele Geschichten. Und ich habe dem im Vorgespräch erzählt, ich habe gestern mit einem Podcaster, Oakheader, drei Stunden telefoniert, der hat mir einfach nur die Vereinsgeschichte Lutentowns erklärt und erzählt. Und was wir gelacht haben, das kann man sich gar nicht vorstellen. Vor allem, wenn man die Platzierungen sieht, ehrlich gesagt. Genau, ja, das und dann gibt es aber, nur als Beispiel, da gibt es eine Dokumentation, die kann man sich auch immer noch anschauen. Das ist auch, keine Ahnung, warum die BBC nie dagegen was gemacht hat. Die gibt es bei YouTube. Ich schaue auch gleich nach, wie sie heißt, weil das habe ich natürlich wieder vergessen. Und da kommt einfach ein neuer Besitzer rein bei Lutentown. Und damals, zu diesem Zeitpunkt, als die gemacht wurde, 2001, gab es gerade British Idol, also die Version, Deutschland sucht den Superstar. Und der dachte sich, es wäre doch eigentlich cool, wenn ich mal den Manager so aussuche. Und das ist wirklich aufgezeichnet. Und das ist doch absolute Weltklasse. Das heißt, trouble at the top. Kann man sich tatsächlich immer noch anschauen, halbe Stunde. Was der Typ allein in den ersten zwei Minuten von sich gibt, der Besitzer, ist absolute Weltklasse. Also es ist wirklich, es ist grandios. Ich kannte das nicht, muss ich zu meiner Schande gestehen, aber es habe ich mir gleich reingezogen und es ist einfach, es ist unglaublich.
Das ist Looten und was ist zu Coventry noch wichtig zu wissen?
Bei Coventry ist es so, letztes Mal in der Premier League gespielt, auch da muss ich noch mal schnell nachschauen, dass ich jetzt komplett keinen Quatsch erzähle. 2001 und seither so oft abgestiegen mussten, also waren beide Teams, das ist auch nochmal interessant zu wissen, 2017, 18. der vierten Liga gemeinsam, gar nicht so lange her. Und bei Coventry ist es auch so, so oft am Rande der Pleite gestanden. 2012, 2013, kein Stadion gehabt bei Luthen. Die waren dreimal Pleite in zehn Jahren. Und trotzdem ist das Fan-Aufkommen nie weggegangen. Das ist bei Coventry genau das Gleiche. Die haben einen furchtbaren Besitzer gehabt, der jetzt endlich seit Januar weg ist. Also, oder eine Gruppe. Jetzt ist es wieder ein einzelner Businessman. Dann ist aber wiederum lange nicht klar gewesen bis April, wo würden die überhaupt spielen nächste Saison, wenn sie aufsteigen, weil das Stadion in der Hand der Rugby-Mannschaft ist. Die sind aber aus Fußballsicht glücklicherweise pleitegegangen, sodass sie jetzt wieder ihren Stadiondeal haben mussten, zwischenzeitlich umziehen, wie bei Luten im Übrigen auch. Und all diese Dinge, diese superbewegten Vergangenheiten, stehen drüber, über diesen Spielen. Und bei Carpentry ist der Kader, selbst ich muss mit Mühe und Not in meinen Aufzeichnungen gucken, dass ich da irgendwas drüber sagen kann, über die einzelnen Spieler, weil das sind de facto unbekannte Menschen. Bei Luten ist es ein bisschen besser. Also da kenne ich schon ziemlich alle. Ich glaube, da sind auch die meisten Leute, die sich einigermaßen mit Fußball interessieren, werden so fünf, sechs, sieben Namen zusammen bekommen. Bei Carpentry ist das krass, weil es einfach geht nicht. Der Trainer ist seit 2017 da, also hat quasi ganz unten übernommen und hat die jetzt allen Ernstes hochgeführt. Und bei Luten ist es eine ähnliche Geschichte. Die könnten binnen neun Jahren von der fünften in die erste Liga gehen, was beispiellos wäre in der Geschichte des englischen Fußballs. Also, dieses Spiel, wenn dir es nicht packt, dann wurscht, wie viel Geld darüber steht, dann kann ich nichts machen.
Das tut mir leid. Wann findet dieses Spiel statt? Wo kann ich es sehen? Und wer kommentiert es?
Der Reihe nach. Samstag, 17.45 Uhr, hoffe, das stimmt. The Zone und Sebastian Kneißel wird es kommentieren, mit mir zusammen.
Ich dachte, für die drei, die es jetzt noch nicht gecheckt haben, zeige ich es noch mal mit dazu.
Ja, das ist ganz wichtig. Es gab eine Diskussion, ob ich das überhaupt noch spielen sollte oder nicht, weil ich eigentlich schon durch bin mit meinen Sachen, die ich so in der Saison machen müsste. Aber da habe ich mich schwer darum beworben, dass ich das gerne machen wollte. Ich hätte es auch so geguckt.
Also Leute, zum Runterkommen, wenn das Saisonfinale in der Bundesliga vorbei ist, könnt ihr euch noch ein bisschen Coventry vs. Luten anschauen. Uli, ich danke dir ganz herzlich für deine Zeit. Und euch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, danke für eure Aufmerksamkeit und für eure Geduld. Danke an alle meine vier Gäste, an Alexis Menuge, an Nils Kern, an Christian Bernhard und Uli Hebel, habt ihr ja gerade eben gehört. Das war Rasenfunk Kurzpass Nummer 267. Bitte unterstützt uns finanziell. Da erfahrt ihr, wie das geht. Und stöbert mal in unseren Feeds. Da sind so einige Sendungen erschienen und da wird auch noch so einiges passieren in unmittelbarer Zukunft. Bis dahin, bleibt gesund, bis bald hier wieder im Rasenfunk.